一条视频讲透志愿填报的一切
每年志愿季我后台都会收到成千上万条私信
这个专业还能报吗
我这个分能冲什么
大学AI来了
哪些专业要避雷
过去5年我已经陪很多人经历过这些难题了
今年这个视频又来了
这一期我会把志愿填报真正重要的东西
一次性全讲透
专业怎么选
学校怎么排
平行志愿怎么填
最后那张志愿表怎么做出来等等等等
你不用到处翻帖子
拿成千上万找机构
也不用被各种营销号带节奏
只需要认认真真看完这一条视频
我的目标只有一个
让你12年的努力
不要输在最后那张志愿表上
如果你是今年的高考生
或者家里有孩子正在填志愿
恳请大家一键三连支持一下这条视频
让这条视频被系统更多的推荐
让更多人能刷到
帮助更多普通家庭的学生
只靠自己也能把高考志愿填好
感谢你的善意
正式开始前
请大家把暴躁打在公屏上
那我们今天的讲解就要正式开始啦
家人们
同学们来
请大家做好以下准备
第一准备一个大屏的浏览器
准备好可以记笔记的工具
我不管你做纸质版笔记还是电子版笔记
第三准备一个安静可思考的环境
今天的内容需要你认真跟上我的思路
一步一步沉浸式的把志愿填报从头到尾过一遍
好家长们
同学们
我们今天的讲解就快要正式开始啦
有没有做好准备
准备好的
按照我们直播间的老传统
把好扣在评论区
我们就正式开讲了
好讲之前我做个小的讲解
因为我每年都会开这个直播
有同学家长曾经看过我2025年的大直播的
对不对
同学这样
如果把这个直播回放放出来以后
你大概率会看这个视频
所以同学如果你看过25年的直播的话
今天这场直播就不用听了
我翻新的部分在第二部分和第三部分
专业选择和院校选择当当中
等我把这个回放放出来以后
你可以看
专门看第二部分和第三部分
但如果您没看过任何之前我的大直播的
今天这场直播从头听到尾
这第一点
第二点
这个视频适合所有省份的同学
2027年
因为我们这个视频会放出来
2027年哎
呃这样同学那个你们现在是哪个哪个哪个年份
哪个年份开
你们都是二六
对不对
有有我们高二高一的吗
有没有2728前缀
有没有
您们把你们的这个填缀年份扣在评论区啊
如果你是当届的家长
没有问题
这当然是你们可以自己看的这26年的选择
如果你是明年27年来看的同学家长的话
请记住所有省份也都适合
唯独有两个省份你要记住
新疆和西藏
要关注关注
因为新疆和西藏他们今年还是老高考的录取
但是明年就会变成新高考
应该我没记错的话
是专业组录取模式啊
但是哪个我不确定啊
到时候你你们通知为准
所以到时候如果是27年来的
新疆和西藏同学的话
请你看确定你们转变成的新高考的模式
就可以不要再看老高考了啊
好家长们
我来简述一下我们今天大概率会讲哪些内容啊
好不好
第一我们会讲工欲善其事
必先利其器
意思是什么
就是如果你要填好一个志愿的话
你必须要关注有哪些相关的工具
因为巧妇难为无米之炊
你没有工具
你怎么去查呢
对不对
第一个我会讲哪些是靠谱的工具
第二个我们会在第二部分去帮你
全面去了解一个专业
因为我们在填志愿时候
最主要的第一个功能是去了解整个专业
对不对
专业你不了解你最后选什么
那一切都是空谈
第三个我们会带你去梳理怎么去看一个大学
怎么去挑院校
怎么做院校的排序
这点很重要
第四个我们就正式进入志愿填报的核心环节
先去帮你理清楚志愿填报你的思路
你的方法来应该如何去做个思考
第五个部分我们就是今天最重点的部分
手把手去带你完成一次志愿填报
包括有调剂成分和无调剂成分
然后最后我会带你去
因为表不是填出来了吗
这表不是填出来了吗
要去看看你哪些地方必须要避坑
这些坑如果你踩中的话
你整个志愿填报可能就会付之东流了
所有努力付之东流
所以今天是我们整场的直播
会以这个结构来展开好
今天我们就正式开讲
家长们
同学们
我们在每个部分过程当中
我们会去简单休息一下
因为我一直讲讲三个小时也也也受不住啊
所以每个部分当中如果大家想休息的话
你可以中间去上厕所
我也会去上个厕所啊
中间休息啊
好不
我们就正式开讲啦
这样同学们来第一个工
欲善其事
必先利其器
首先哪些是您在高考填报志愿过程当中
必须要掌握的工具和信息源呢
有力气啊
家长们来第一个阳光高考
阳光高考相信这个网站你们绝对不陌生
你们在上面可以查到很多的权威信息
甚至很多你们要完成高爆的
比如说提前批啊
什么强基综评
很多东西你可能要在上面去完成
对不对
阳光高考在上面你能查什么东西
我点进来啊
嗯在上面看到吗
阳光志愿这边你可以查院校
查专业
上面有各种各样的院校和专业可以选择
然后再往下这儿有个全国高等学校的名单
看到这儿看到没有
这个是最新的2026届的
最新的高等教育学校的名单
能够帮你去避免一些野鸡大学
特别低分段的同学
很多那种那种中介很坏的啊
和你说什么
你上什么大学
最后其实都是野鸡大学
这上面是没有的
然后再往下很重要的是什么呢
在这就是在高考填志愿的时候
很多相关的高考常识
你可以在这边去做一个相关的那个扫盲
然后再往上在这啊看到吗
全国各高校和省市招办王者导航
如果你不知道怎么去你们省教育考试院
或者不知道怎么去找每个学校
它的招生官网在这边能够一站式的查找
这就是阳光高考好不好
阳光好看这下
然后第二个啧
各位家长
各位同学
一定要去你们本省的省教育考试院官网
你后面什么一分一段表
你去查分查各种录取的通知
然后查各种各样的录取的分数线
在本省
都是在你们本省的省教育考试院官网里面去查
而这个东西一般来说在你们孩子的这个呃
准考证的背面有网址
如果没有的话
哎你可以去查
就刚才那个阳光高考啊
你往下去翻
能够去直接找到你们本省的省教育考试院官网
你就不用去白某度啦
这个可能是弄些什么野鸡网站都说不定啊
所以避免避免踩雷
直接进阳光高考都可以
都能找到你们各省的省教育考卷
然后家长同学第三个很重要
我问个问题
你们有没有做过志愿填报的预案
就比如说我现在孩子大概什么位次
什么分数
我能够到哪些的院校
这个预案有没有做好
有做好的扣一
当你做到这个预案的时候
我建议啊
把你自己分数和位次能够到的这些院校去看看
他的招生公众号
招生官网
所有这个学校它的比如说今年的招生计划
他往年的录取情况
他最新的招生政策都会在这里面去公布
比如说我举个例子
因为我是复旦的嘛
我给大家举个复旦例子
点复旦大学招生网进去以后嗯
哎你看各种招生动态
对
对招生章程什么这个综合评价
三位一体等等等
都在上面要做公式啊
所以这个东西你要留存好
这东西很重要哦
好以上这三个是你必须要关注的
填报志愿的工具和渠道
但是我们为了填好志愿
我们还有一些可以选择的工具和渠道有哪些
来第一个怎么去看大学和专业的排行
我这边主要推荐一个叫做软科
其实针对本科专业的排行
本科大学的排名
是完全没有去做过的
都是一些民间的机构去做过的
哎
比如说软科
是我个人觉得我自己最推崇的一个相关的这个
民间机构网站
你看比如说大学的排名
学科的排名
专业的排名等等等
在里面全部都有啊
而且最新的2026年的排名也都有了哟
所以你可以在里面去做个查找啊
这个针对是大学和专业
然后再往下
刚才说是本科所讲的是专科
对不对
来我们直播间有没有中高分段同学扣一
什么叫中高分段
就如果能上985211双一流
普一版
普二本的叫做中高分段扣一
如果是中高分段
你们在填报志愿的时候
你一定还要去查查什么呢
叫做学科评估
学科评估是针对这个学校
他的研究生的学科的排行
好不好
我推荐你可以去查两个第四轮的学科评估
看能看哪个呢
对不对
在下面拉到下面哎呦
全部都能查到
比如说哲学呀
经济学啊
理学呀
工学呀
力学呀
机械啊等等
全部都有
全部在里面都可以查到
哪个最方便
叫做青塔网点
青塔啊
进去以后诶
家人们这个你可看不清楚啊
呃因为在我的屏幕外
你可以在左边去检索具体的某一个学校
他就会把这个学校所有的学科评估的结构
给你展示出来
所以这个啊你可以去看青塔网
OK记下了吗
好再往下
因为我们国家目前为止呢
只公布了第四轮的学科评估
他没公布第五轮的
第五轮的学科评估都是在各个学校
各个各个招生口
或者他们自己的一些呃
讲座里面去零星的做了一个发布
所以如果你想查第五轮的学科评估
家长同学可以叫什么
我个人比较推荐一个叫做研学小岛的公某号
在他的置顶文章里面会有A类的
第五轮学科评估好不好
所以如果孩子中高分段学科评估
你要看一看啊
这个可以从这些地方来查
然后呢如果是关于专
因为刚才讲的是一些客观的排名嘛
对不对
他们可能排下来有分数有位次
但是听起来会比较冷冰冰的
那有没有一些比较主观的分享呢
关于专业的主观分享哎有的有的同学家都有的
你可以去看一个叫取景框看世界的这个博主啊
这个博主呢从20112021年到现在啊
每一年他都去更新了很多很多的专业访谈
上面有985的
211的双一流的哎
这个普一本
普二本甚至专科的各个层次
各个专业方向的这个人都有去做调查
所以说取景框看世界这个博主呢
大家就可以去关注关注了啊
他上面有很很多的这个专业的主观分享啊
好不好
这第一个看视频可以去了解了解啊
这个博主真的很不错啊
记得啊一定要去看呵呵
然后呢还可以去干什么叫框框大学
这个网站是取景框看世界
这个博主他做的一个网站
现在这个网站上已经有了1万多条
关于专业的相关的分享
而且都是不同学校
不同专业的同学自己主观的分享
来家长你还可以干嘛
左上边诶你可以去检索专业
看计算机软件
汉语言文学新语文
它上面已经有几百个专业都可以去做选择哟
我举个例子啊
比如说你们就看计算机科学技术哎
点个计算机
刚才检索出来是所有结果哎
现在300多条关于计算机的结果就全部出来
上面是各个院校的相关的分享
在上面都可以查到
然后你可以看学校
按学校来检索
哎呦
所有学校在上面也都能检索到啊
好不好都能找到
而且不止学校检测
还看不同学历要求的检索
比如说专科生的分享
本科生的分享
硕士生的分享
博士生的分享
而且你还可以基于工作经验做检索
哎呦没有工作的是高年级学生来做的分享
刚刚步入职场的分享
和步入职场5年以上的分享
而家长们结束了吗
没有结束
你一定要看旁边
这是不是有个最新看到吗
这里有个最新看到没有
最新是按时间排序的
你可以点按人气排序
点完以后这个相关的筛选结果当中
点赞数哎
怎么哇哦终于出来了
可能用的人太多了
因为高暴击哈哈哈哈
点赞数最多
也就是说相对而言被更多人认可的回答
就能优先做个展示
而这个东西是取景框
看世界纯公益免费制作的网站
没有任何的收费
家长们一定要用啊
好不好啊
嗯唉能不能把谢谢框框打在评论区啊
能不能把谢谢框框打在评论区啊
这个曲景观看世界的这个博主还挺好的啊
对吗
哈哈哈哈好啦
刚才讲的是关于专业的主观分享
那接下来很多同学同学我问你一个问题啊
请问你关不关心在这个学校里面去读本科
去读专科
他的就读体验到底如何
关心的扣一如果你真的关心的话
哎关于院校的主观分享
我个人相对比较推荐一个网站
叫做大学生活质量指北
点击进去啊
这个网站你能在上面查所有你能查到的学校诶
他这个学校你左边都可以选选院校啊
啧这个学校看右边啊
宿舍是上床下桌吗
教室和宿舍有没有空调
是独立卫浴吗
有早晚自习吗
有晨跑吗
跑步打卡吗
寒暑假放多少
允许点外卖吗
就是所有关系到你大学生活的幸福体验感的
所有内容在上面都有
而且同学家长一定要点一下这个点击展开啊
因为很多学校很多它是基于调研问卷嘛
很多学校调研问卷相对来说比较的古老
如果比如说是22年的问卷
可能他参考意义就不是很大了
你最好要参考比较靠前的
现在2526年的问卷好不好啊
这是关于院校的主观分享
叫大学生活质量职位
你可以去看看好不好
OK啊
然后最后各位站各位同学
你们一定会去参考很多志愿工具
我我问个问题
如果您已经购买过一些嗯
志愿填报的智能工具的
比如优质愿呐
笔袋呀
掌上高考啊
或者旷硕
我自己的re AI的
有的扣一
有没有有的扣一
如果您购买过任何的志愿工具
它帮你查数据非常的便捷
能帮你减少工作量
我建议你要参考
但家长同学
如果你完全只依赖于一个软件
一个app去做智能填志愿这功能
我建议你谨慎
为什么叫同学
每一套系统它是不是都基于一个固定的算法
那万一这个算法在你身上失灵了怎么办
所以如果你要用这个东西的话
我建议你啊买个两三个交叉验证
能不能听懂好不好啊
家长们
同学们
那今天我们的第一部分刚刚讲完
第一部分很简单
就先不休息啊
家长同学好不好
第一部分我们就不去讲
接着来讲第二部分啊
怎么去了解专业
了解专业以后怎么帮你做一个专业的决策好
第一个
首先我请问各位同学
各位家长
你最近肯定在密切的关注
各种关于志愿填报的话题对吗
但你有没有发现
当我去看了很多这些话题以后
怎么所有专业都在劝退啊
发现了没有发现的扣一哼哇
我想读新闻
新闻在劝退
我想读计算机
计算机在劝退
我想读土木
土木没行情
我想读电子信息
电子信息太难了
劝退自动化还自动化
本科不行
万金油劝退
发现了没有
那啥都不能学了呗
这样同学没有必要如此焦虑
请你理性看待网上的劝退
为什么来我们思考一个话题
首先如果给你去做这样的观点的是大学生家长
请问现在6月份是大学的什么时候
是不是期末季
站长同学
一个大学生对于本专业的厌恶程度
会在期末即到达顶点
所有专业皆是如此
如果给你发表意见呢
是一些从业人家长同学
说实话
哪有一个人就一直干这工作
一直爱本行的吗
所以他有可能给你输出的
就是相关的工作上的情绪
而且很多学生很多从业人
他们仅他们的视角仅仅局限在诶我这个专业
我这个行业本身他不了解其他专业
他不能做个横向对比
只能针对本专业发表意见
所以你说这样的推荐
这样的劝退对你来说有参考价值吗
参考价值并没有那么高
所以理性看待专业劝退好不好
不用如此焦虑
我们直播间从来不传递焦虑
我们从来给北从来都是给解决方案的
对不对
那怎么选专业
我们待会讲啊
然后我要提
我要请各位同学给我讲
再警惕个东西
我们直播间如果您去不到顶尖的高分段
比如说你去不到清华北大
去不到华东五校
去不到中国人民大学
去不到北航
北理这种中国顶尖的985的扣一
这同学去不到顶尖高校的扣一
各位同学
各位家
你有没有发现在中文互联网上针对一个专业
针对一个行业发表观点做分享的
大部分是精英人群
也就是说刚才我讲的这种顶尖酒保的人对吗
带你见你同学
他们的意见真的能够对普通人具备参考价值吗
你是一个普一本普二本
你是个专科的清华
和你说计算机前途无量
这应该参考吗
对你的参考意义就极其的小
所以这点怎么解决
各位站各位同学哎
你就要谨记一个叫取景框看世界的博主的
好了呀
因为他做视频
做网站的时候
会照顾到所有层次同学和这个家长啊
高分段中分段
低分段都有啊
所以你可以在我的是哦哦不是我就呵呵哦
不是就是就是那个这个就就是呃就就我啊
我就群游看世界啊
就可以在取景框看世界
这个博主这边
让你找到能够专属于你的学历层次
然后对你展开了相关的分享啊
就这样的情况啊
哈哈哈好
这是第二点
第三点来
这位同学
我请问你认不认可我家孩子选志愿的时候
应该看他的兴趣
用兴趣给我做志愿填报的决定
认可的扣一
不认可的扣二
兴趣能帮你做志愿填报专业选择的决定权吗
请告诉我应不应该应不应该不应该
为啥绝大部分孩子在进大学之前
根本不知道自己喜欢什么
同学肯定有这样的人
我喜欢高中的数学
我对高中数学贼感兴趣
我大学选择数学专业
我对高中的物理
对高中化学贼感兴趣
我大学选择物理化学专业
但家长同学们
高中的学科和大学专业是完全不同的两码事
所以不要凭借你在高考之前朴素的兴趣
认为我真的喜欢什么
很多人入学入行了以后
发现自己才真的不喜欢这个好不好
所以说各位家长
如果你要把兴趣当做选择专业的选择的话
我建议做决定权不要
但他一定能帮你做排除法
因为唉我们这边肯定有啊
有没有就这辈子都不想都不想再碰到数学
不想碰到物理的
有没有扣个一吧啊
同学有没有啊
这辈子碰到数学
碰到物理
我脑壳都大
那如果你这样的同学
那就完全就应把数学物理专业排除了吗
听到没有啊
所以他能帮你做排除法
不能帮你做决定权
OK好好再往下
各位站
各位同学
我请问你们有没有去做过什么MBTI
有没有把你的MMBTI的人格发在评论区
什么IESFJ啊
EMPT啊
这个这什么MPTI
你肯定做过很多同学很喜欢做这个东西啊
什么扣在评论区
这样同学
如果你去做过什么MBTI
或什么霍兰德职业测试
以及其他各种职业和工作导向的相关测试的话
请你们记住这个东西
它会受制于你当下做这个测试的心理水平
心理心境
而且再过几年
可能你的性格特征会发现一点点的转行和偏航
所以他给你导出这个推荐不一定适合你
但同学家长
我请问你的性格偏好
你能做一个180度的完全的转向吗
这不太可能吧
所以如果你做出这个东西
你可以把它帮用它来帮你做排除法
这个没有任何问题好吧
所以这两个啊兴趣和职业测试
性格测试都是帮你做排除法
但不能帮你做决定权
这个时候肯定就这样
我同学来和我说
那孔老师那什么叫做科学的专业选择方法论呢
家长同学有没有说过
逛过很多直播间
和你说
哎呀我们中国14个专业门类接近啊
90多个专业大类接近900个专业
我听得人都懵了
这么多专业让我一天了解一个
我这个两三天这个两三年我都搞不清楚
对不对
哎听起来很焦虑
哎呀好老师
我就在你报一对一吧
这不帮你塑造焦虑嘛
没必要没必要怎么去选择专业
这样的同学把这两个字扣在评论区
排除排除啊
排除两个字扣在评论区
什么叫做最科学的专业选择步骤
用排除法
第一个用什么排除
用自己的选科做初次排除
这个不用我说了吧
这样的同学
你是个文科
你为什么要去了解理工科专业
你根本选不到啊
你是个物理
没有选化学同学
你能选的也是物理加不限
以及其他的不限的选择专业啊
你如果是物化的
这个我要提醒一下啦
我们直播间有没有啊
就是比如说你是物化双选的同学
然后你未来呢打算选择文理兼招的专业
比如说以经管法学为例
有没有的扣一你是理科生
但你有可能会选择法学
经管类的扣一有没有
这个我要和你说一下啊
有没有有没有
所以扣一的同学家长
我个人建议啊
对于法学而言
没有必要
你本科选理工科
研究生转法学
你未来还更多一条知识产权的这个路子
你未来路子更宽
如果你本科是理工科
你未来读研转经管转金融
你以后还能做很多很多行业的行业研究
现在的金融业界非常喜欢
跨学科的复合背景的人才
所以如果你家孩子是理科生啊
我个人我个人建议啊
你就不要本科优选这种文理建造专业了
本科优选理工科是一个更好的选择
然后这个呢就是整个选科
你们在选择专业时有什么限制条件
能选什么
不能选什么
这个在我们的决胜志愿里面都有啊
这个是我的书里面做个总结的好不好
但是一定要注意啊
不同学校它可能有些个性化的要求
所以你们在填志愿的时候
他自己还做了一些什么样细致的排除
细致的选课限制
好不好
自己可以做个调研啊
可以把空调开低一点点啊
好这样的同学们
这第一个用选科做排除
第二个我请问我们不是都做过高考体检吗
你们那个体检表单上有没有叫受限代码的东西
出现什么二一啊
二二啊
二三呐
三一啊
三二啊
这种受限代码有的可以
有没有这同学
如果你有这个受限代码的话
你要关注关注
用体检指标做二次排除
但是这个要关注一下啊
啊这个体检指标我这里给大家列了一个
你们可以搜这个东西
叫做普通高等学校招生体检工作指导报告
指导意见
这个是04年左右我们国家发的一个文件了
很多高校现在仍然在执行
但是你也要关注一下学校
它本身有没有对于体检更多的标注
但是在这个过程当中
我最想让你们关注两个名字
一个叫做不语录取
家长们
同学们
如果他上面写的是不予录取的话
你一定要谨慎
在你的志愿表单上
你就不要把这个专业给他放上去了
因为不予录取
我可以不录你
所以这非常可怕
但如果它上面显示不宜就读
这个您不用关注
这个只是说你未来在呃学习
在工作时候会有一些障碍
但是从高校他们在额招生的过程当中
所以不予录取和不宜就读
关注不予录取
要更多关注关注啊
这是用体检帮你做二次排除
好不好好
第三个用学科偏好做三次排除
来这点很重要啦
很多同学都有自己的学科偏好啊
来直播间站的同学
如果这辈子不想再碰到数学的扣一哈哈哈哈
这辈子不想碰到数学的扣一哈哈哈呵
那同学如果这辈子都不想碰到数学了啊
纯数学专业你不要碰
统计专业为什么也不要碰呢
因为统计本身在13年之前属于数学大类
但是现在单独拎出来
他成一个单独的大类
他的妈妈就是数学啊
所以统计你也不要学计算机和人工智能
尤其是人工智能偏向于软的方向
这样同学这个工科非常特殊
几乎只吃数学
不吃物理
所以如果你要学的话
那计算机人工智能
那你也把他排除排除了
除此以外
经济管理类专业他也比较吃数学
会计就属于管理嘛
家长这个有什么好问的呢
经济管理类专业呢
如果你就只读到本科哎
可能平时数学大概及格就行了
但是但是啊如果你未来想读硕读博
经管类专业数学再好都不过分
你如果考研的时候
经管啊
特别是你要考学硕的时候
数学要考数学
进入研究生
一进入硕博生的培养考核里面
尽管有大量的数学
我给你举个例子吧
我自己就是学经济学的本科
很多经济学什么微观经济学
宏观经济学
他学的是经济学的现象
给你讲经济学的故事
但读硕读博了以后
你知道吗
我们读什么中级高级微观宏观经济学
全是数学模型
全是理论推导
我的导师跟我说句
跟我说过一句话
空旷啊
如果来读经济学的博士
你的数学再好都不过分
听懂了吗
所以家长同学不想碰数学的话
那这些你要谨慎谨慎了啊
当然后面关注一句话
所有的理工科它的基础都有数学
这这里我只是把关于数学最紧要的关系
给你放在这好
第二个
我们直播间有没有这辈子都不想碰到物理的
有没有有的扣一啊
有没有这辈子不想碰物理了
物理是我一生之敌啊哈哈
太出现这些模型怎么去搞的
就搞不懂呵
如果你这辈子培养彭波
碰到物理
请谨记
绝大部分的功课的基础都有物理
所以大概率啊大部分的工科你全部都要排除好
上面这几个呢是比较代表性的工科
我给他标出来啊
为什么我把呃这个这个不好意思
这个物理这个物理搞错了
这个不应该标黄
首先物理你肯定本身这专业你就不要读了
那剩下这些专业
电子信息自动化
电气仪器
我为什么给他变成黄色
这些专业他更加吃物理当中的力学
更而更吃物理当中的电学
所以如果你电学很瘸腿
那这四个专业方向逻辑你就谨慎进去了
后面像什么机械啊
航空天啊
船舶兵器能动啊
这些专业呢
他更加吃的是力学
所以他们的方向并不太一样好不好
这是不太吃啊
不是更吃物理的相关的学科
然后下面这两个一个叫化工
一个叫材料
这两个工科专业他们更加吃的是物理和化学
如果你物理化学相对比较瘸腿
那么我个人就没有
那么建议你优先考虑这两个专业啦
然后生化不分家
在大学当中
如果你要读化学
化学主要看纯化学啊
要读生物
读食品
生物工程
环境医学
药学农学
动物科学
动物医学等等等等
他们比较适应的化学和生物
如果你这辈子不想碰到化生了
那这些专业呢你就要谨慎谨慎就不要考虑了
还有一个相对来说比较特殊专业
叫做生物医学工程
生医工这个专业相当于生物医学加电子信息
电子信息又吃数学
又吃物理
对不对
生物医学他吃生物加化学啊
所以这个专业物化生都要吃
所以如果你这辈子不想再碰理科了
那么生医工你就不要碰了啊
好不好
所以各位让各位同学嗯
用你的学科偏好做三次排除
做完三次排除以后
你大概率可能接近900个专业
你就没能读
就没几个了
可能也就这个五六十个了
就七八十个了
没那么多了
那第四次排除我就个人建议啊
你用框框
我自己的专业大类科普视频做四次排除
我在2021年6月份发过八期视频
全部都是大一大类专业的深度科普
然后你可以用一个下午的时间
因为就八期视频
每个视频也就不到一个小时
用一个下午的视频刷刷刷
全部过一遍
把你自己呢这个就是比较感兴趣的都过一下诶
发现嗯和我自己想的不一样
你也可以把他排除出去
但是有家长会问了孔老师啊
都2026年了
你2021年的专业还有参考价值吗
所以为了能够适应2026年最新的趋势
我决定过几天发一个半个小时
速通中国所有大学的短视频正在制作
请期待符合2026年AI替代下的完整趋势
怎么样可不可以啊
请把谢谢框框打在评论区
好不好啊
哈哈哈哈哈好啦
这是帮你们看大类吗
看完大类以后哦
我刚才剩七八十个大类
排完以后哦
只剩下二三十个了
你排除完了以后
各位同学各位
这样你就要对具体的专业做深度了解了吗
对不对
我比如说我还能选择有计算机大类
有电子信息大类
那每个大里面每个细分专业应该是什么呢
叫同学怎么对具体专业做一个相关的深入了解
哎你就可以看看取景框看世界
他从221年到现在
一直更新的专业深度科普视频
他到目前为止做过了计算机
土木电子信息
经济财政金融
经济贸易
自动化仪器
数学统计
机械历史呃
工商管理管理
科学工程
农业经济管理
工商公共管理
图书情报管理
物流管理
工业工程
电子商务
旅游管理
法学电气
中国园文学
临床口腔
心理教育
社会材料
声音工
能源动力地理测绘
化学化工外语物物理
天文地球物理力学等等等
所有的八九十%的专业在全部做完科普
而且他的科普是关于985211普本专科
全面的分享
相当于做了一个坐标轴
横轴是中国所有的专业
纵轴是中国所有的院校层次
在其中一定能找到
更加适合你的背景的嘉宾的分享
不这是这个博主对于中文互联网的贡献
你就可以基于刚才你最后排除的二三十个专业
在里面对标去看哪个专业你更加的OK
家长同学做完以上内容
那么你的专业不就全部定下来了吗
懂了没有
但是今天我们再额外探讨一个话题
这样同学我不知道你们关不关心当下
20252026人工智能AI发展如此之快
对于各大专业到底有什么影响
关心的扣一老师是哪个博主取景框看世界
老师我们看不过来啊
怎么可能看不过来
同学家长
我刚才说了
你先做排除法
你先把比如说接近900多个专业排除出来
排除到最后只剩下二三十个专业
针对这二三十个专业
你针对去看相关的专业视频
谁让你都看啊啊
谁让你都看
你
那这个时间你都看完
那你就你就是我同行了哈
好
接下来我们讲讲
人工智能时代对于各大专业的影响
首先第一个对于主流工科的影响
计算机我的答案是
因为人工智能替代在当下中低分段
绝大部分同学不能读计算机了
因为真的被AI替代完了
低分段尤其不能读
我们直播间怎么啊
我再说一下怎么定位高中低分段
高分段叫985211双一流
顶尖的普本院校
中分段叫普通一本
普通二本
好不好
低分段计算机完全不能学
千万不能选啊
我们直播间加你直播部都不能选
中分段95%的同学不能学
如果你是最后那5%的同学
你必须满足两大要求
必须同时满足
第一你自己对编程极其有兴趣
这样能够逼迫你去自学
因为计算机极其吃自学
第二一定要选择好的互联网资源
比较发达的城市
在我们整个中国境内
我有且仅有推荐八个城市
排名有先后
记住北京上海深圳广州杭州成都
这六所非常推荐
然后勉强能算一算
武汉和南京中分段同学
如果不能满足这两个当中的任何一个计算机
都不能读
高分段可以读
因为人工智能需要高分段的计算机的技术驱动
这计算机
然后电子信息自动化
机械电气全部因为人工智能的发展
尤其是因为人工智能偏向于硬件的发展
对他们有了更大的需求
电子信息AI算力芯片自动化
聚生智能机械巨生智能智能人形机器人
电气也是智能人形机器人
所以未来偏硬的工科仍然有大发展
而且很难被AI替代
好再往下讲
完了比较主流工科的影响
再来看理科的影响
数学统计这样专业
如果你做的是基础的数据的工种的话
其实真的会被AI替代完
但是各位同学
各位家长
我不是讲过吗
数学本身需要教孩子
数学极其牛逼
最好我个人认为
平时数学能够稳定够到125以上
你再考虑高
再考虑大学数学专业
而且125都不一定能用
你一定让孩子先去看看大学里面的两门课程
一门叫做数学分析
一门叫做高等代数
如果他啃得下来再学数学
所以满足这个条件的人凤毛麟角
几乎都是高分段
那数学能学中低分段数学
你学它干嘛
你也学不懂
也成不了才没有必要统计
也是统计
本身他的妈妈就是数学专业
所以我个人建议
平时孩子最好高中能稳定上到120分
再考虑统计
那既然如此的话
绝大部分也是高分段的选择
但高分段你选的统计
那是很好的AI的方向
因为我们直播间曾经多次强调过
人工智能是一个很复杂的前沿交叉学科
来大家都打在评论区啊
都打在评论区
人工智能有三大底层学科
计算机自动化和统计
为什么统计是人工智能底层学科
因为机器没有视觉
没有感官
他不知道何为人
何为狗
何为猫
它必须要大量的数据投喂才会知道
而这个东西需要统计的技术
所以如果孩子是高分段学了统计
你不是被人工智能替代
你是人工智能的技术人才好不好啊
然后再往下讲
商科基础的财务
基础的会计
基础的财务管理
其实上课呢现在真的被人工智能替代蛮多的
但是商科有一层很深层次的原因是
很多人要去做营销
要去做人与人的链接
这方面你做销售
做人与人链接
做人脉资源的链接
这个方向现在被AI还没有取代
所以如果刘商科一定要锻炼自己的外向能力
做一个高情商的人
做能够和人与人链接的资源的人
否则的话你读商科你会非常吃亏
未来大概率有很多的工种
很多的工序你可能会被AI替代
再往下家
人们文科当中汉语言外语法学汉语言外语
我讲过无数遍了
你这个翻译都被AI替代完了
现在你如果读文科
读语言类专业
真的是自找天坑
我个人没那么主动推荐啊
但是我们直播间有没有分数挺高的
文科生的
有没有有吗
有没有就是能上到顶尖985的
以清华北大
华东五校
中国人民大学
武汉大学
南开大学等等
以此为界的顶尖九八的
扣个一虽然不多
但我和你们讲讲
如果你读汉语言
读语言学
读应用语言学
读底层的语料
读智能语言语言语言智能这种相关专业的话
你未来能够转AI
能够做人工智
人工智能的自然语言处理方向
现在在过去这5年
大量的顶尖酒吧的文科生走了这个方向啊
听到了吗
但是啊很吃学历好
再往下法学法学家长同学
如果你做基础的文本的整理
现在AI做的又好又快
我个人预测啊
法学未来会受到AI的大量的冲击啊
哈哈哈哈好
再往下设计设计就拉完了
设计不是现在设计在前年吧
几乎就被AI替代完了
就现在如果你是做什么呃
图片设计啊
做什么呃
视频设计
动效设计啊
很多很多现在已经成熟的AI工具
都能把你替代了
那等你44年毕业
5年毕业
等你硕博毕业
那那个时候设计人工智能怎么去带
已经不知道发展到什么什么好的程度了
所以说这个就是我们现在去讨论一下
AI时代啊
对不同的专业的意志性的影响好不好好了
家长同学们
那我们先啊先大概用了40分钟
把第一部分和第二部分都做了一个讲解好不好
那么家人们
我们先正好哎正好差不多37分钟啊
我们先休息2分钟
接下来7.40
我们开始下一个部分好不好
讲院校的部分
OK好啊
我现在先不上厕所啊
你们有什么问题可以在评论区啊
你们可以先上个厕所休息一下啊
好不好
课间休息2分钟啊
40正式开始下一个部分啊
家人们
同学们有什么问题可以扣在评论区啊
有没有问题
关于刚才讲解的东西
有没有什么问题啊
老师请问这个文档你以后会分享吗
会的啊
这个我会和回放一起发出来啊
哎哎做个小调查
我们这边有今天第一次刷到我的吗
今天我们直播间人太多了
我们直播间1万5000人在线
从来没有这么多人啊
呵呵有没有第一次刷到我的我们三平台嘛
第一次刷到我的
有没有啊
第一次刷到我的家长
如果你是高三很值得关注
因为我是讲大学规划出身的
我的主页有贼多的大学规划的视频
我自己本人在复旦做了6年辅导员
2020年做曲靖文
开设这个账号以来
收获了全网接近700万的粉丝
全部都是学生
那如果你是高一高二家长
那你更应该关注了啊
我们直播间一直讲高爆的啊
说实话
全平才在今天能够做到1万5000人在线
直播间有几个啊
没几个
是不是啊
值得点关注啊
呵来请问文科生咋整
文科生不是说了吗
文科生最好的专业就是法学和经管嘛
但其实哎我们可以探讨一下加长同学
你觉得文科生最好的专业方向在哪
其实不在法学
也不在经管
文科生最好的专业在提前批
你认可吗
呵呵但提前批不是所有人都能上的啊
所以如果你上不了提前批同学家长记住
不用太关注专业
你要关注的是第一院校层次
你要评院校层次吃饭
第二关注地区
因为文科生大量的岗位全部都是现代服务业
城市越好
现代服务业岗位越多
能听懂吗
文科生
关注老师10年了
你在说什么啊
我做自媒体
从2020年到现在也就6年
你关注10年
你你时光机啊
呵呵呵呵呵呃呵呵啊
不不能打SC
我们直播间不能打SC啊
不回答SC
老师我们重庆是不是流川渝比较好呃可以
如果你想留重工业
制造重工业的话
留重庆
如果你想去一些现代服务产业的话
去成都啊
整个西南片区经济活力还挺挺足的
没有任何问题
SC是什么
是RB1那个平台的一个一个东西啊
您不用管
而中分段能读人工智能
不不不不
中分段不能读人工智能
高分段才能读
哎家长这样的啊
这样这样这样来来租个小预告
这样的同学
如果你关注现在我正在讲的这些热门热门专业
包括工科
包括理科
包括商科
您关注的话
不同分数段怎么做选择
要不这样
因为今天没办法大展开了
明天早上可以来我们直播间
早上八点钟讲这个内容好不好
下面听计算机高中低分段怎么选择
电子信息
高中低分段怎么选择
自动化
数学统计
高中低分段怎么选择啊
明天早上啊
好不好
就这样
到点了
讲课了讲课讲课讲课讲课了讲课了好
第三个部分
我们来谈谈怎么去挑选院校
挑选院校有哪些核心的指标
一步步来啊
首先我们要看院校层次
院校层次几乎是我们在挑院校时候
最主要的因素
为什么同学让我提问
现在有两个学校摆在你面前
A南京大学的机器人工程
南大的控制学科是CEO
第二东北大学自动化
东北大学的控制
它是A加哟
请问一还是二
如果你选的话
选一还是选二
选哪个选一还是选二
选哪个
你看你看你看你看怎么回事
这么多二这样同学选择院校的时候
第一排序叫做院校层次
南京大学的院校层次比东北大学不止高了
两个档位
优选南京大学选二的很多啊
好不好
所以这也要科普啊
我们的院校层次
如果你去看的话
目前为止一般有这几类
双一流普本和专科
专科里面很多同学会说
矿老师给你们讲讲专科怎么做分类
你就看双高计划
有双高计划的就是比较好的专科好不好
这个时候就这样会纠结了
如果我的分数大概又能够到985
又能够到二幺是中下游
报好中上二要怎么做
选择很简单
看以下几个维度
第一看孩子有没有确定的专业偏好
如果有的话
优选行业特色二幺第二他未来想不想深造
如果想深造
大概率同层次的话
985的保研率和升学率要更高
我只是大概率啊
有些地方不是啊
比如说呃北邮西电等等
它和同层次的985就拉不开差距
甚至它保研率更高
但大部分情况下
九八和二要对比的话
985保研率更高
这第二第三
如果你本科就就业
优选行业特色的211
因为他们这个行业里面是有影响力的
但如果你想进体制走选调生优选985
因为选调生更加吃院校层次
更加吃985
第四看你孩子未来如果本科就就进教
教选地区的话
2111般来说比985地区更好
第五如果孩子是理科生
优选工科强
是211
如果是文科生
优先选院校层次走985
如果是医科生
98521不重要
更加看的是你们当地的地头蛇的属性
9851怎么选择
这么选择好
如果有家长孩子在211和普本里面纠结
有的比如说我能去末流偏远的211
和经济相对比较发达地区的普本院校
这个时候也考虑两点
第一点未来要不要持续升学
如果要读硕读博优选211
如果未来就想本科毕业后就就业
优选普北
因为他们城市更好
就这么简单好不好
这个是越要层次
然后第二个我们中国大学一般呢划分为这几个
一个叫综合大学
一个叫理工大学和专门大学
什么叫专门大学
什么叉叉医科大学
叉叉民族大学啊
这种就是专门类大学
他们的学科门类的相对没有那么齐全啊
是专门为一个体系来服务的
然后我们这边也还去区分他的公办
民办和中外合办呃
公办不用说了
民办有个很重要的特征
就是它学费比较贵
因为民办一般是企业或者是呃相关的团体
他们来出资设立这个学校
所以一般来说民办院校学费更贵
那你可以掂量掂量自己
到底能支撑你这个学费啊
然后中外合作中外合办呢
一般来说从院校层次来说是指S11
就是中外独立合作反人类院校
他们的学费更贵
但如果你要读什么上海纽约大学
昆山杜克大学这种中外合办的话
它的外生质量很好
所以这个你可以多关注关注
这个不重要啊
我只简单略过一下
这个不重要
最重要是刚才讲的985211
相关的院校层次
这个相对比较重要啊
好再往下办学经费
办学经费就比较重要了
因为办学经费决定你能引进什么师资
有什么实验器材
能做什么样的科研
能发什么文章
给学生如何的生活就读体验
所以经费越高的地方
其实相对来说也更值得去读
一般的经费的规律呢是部属大学大于省属大学
经济发达省份的经费
会多于经济欠发达的省份的这个经费
理工类大学要多于其他大学
为什么
因为理工科特别是工科
再加上一科
他很吃经费
所以这经费啊
但经费统计的排名呢
其实你们可以在各种各样的自媒体
各种各样的机构
他们都会去做一个汇总
最新的2026年的
各大高校的经费预算已经出炉了
你们可以去搜都能在网上搜到的啊
好不好
这个你们到处都可以搜到的
这个没那么重要
但接下来就重要了
我提个问题
咱们直播间同学家长
如果你读了本科以后
未来打算读硕读博的
扣一有没有有没有读完本科以后
未来打算读书读博的
可以啊
那你们务必要关注一个指标叫做升学率数据
但升学率数据它一共分成三种
什么叫升学率
比如说如果升学率是60%
意味着诶
我把这个100个学生送到你们这个学校以后
未来有60个学生能够读上研究生
但我不管我不管他是通过保研上的
还是通过考研上的
还是通过留学上的
只要他上了研究生
就数算进升学数据里面
那么其实升学率就等于保研率
加考研率加留学率啊
所以从这个角度而言
各位站各位同学
考研会受到学校氛围的影响
留学会受到家境的影响
从理论上来说
保研率考研率都会做到很高
但是保额报这考研率和留学率都能做的很高
但是保研率不会有大的浮动
为什么
因为每一年上面教某部
他批给各个高校的保研指标不会有大的扩张
所以这三个指标里面请谨记
保研率相对来说更有含金量
那么有这样就会说了
孔老师啊
那保研率可以从哪去看呢
哎呀送佛送到西嘛
我已经帮你在一个公众号叫做星球数据派上
扒下来的一个保研率的数据
从2020届到2025届
相对而言很科学的
每一个学校它的保研率数据全部展示在这儿
到时候等我把这个回放放出来以后
这个课件你们都可以去看
直接每个学校都有
这个时候是不是值得点个关注
点个点赞
点个收藏
这么好的直播间
这么好的老师不值得数据支持一下吗
啊送佛送到西啊
哈哈哈好啦
这个是保研率啊
这是保研率
然后大同学们
然后是优势学科
在哪可以看各个学校的优势学科呢
你肯定知道吗
如果要去读一个学校
那我去做去读他的一个固定专业
这个专业他实力强不强
对不对
第一个看学科评估
刚才讲过了
从哪看学科评估啊
教某部的网站
青塔网
研学小岛都能看
对不对
学科评估每5年会再做一次
学科评估
是基于过去这5年的评价
代表这个学校传统的优势学科方向
第二个双一流学科
如果你孩子读的是双流
那么学双一流一定要去看看啊
这个这个数据很容易找到
我的书里面也有啊
双一流有的时候会和学科评估打架
因为有很多人会发现哎呦
怎么一个学校的双一流
他的学科甚至还没有他的学科评估
这个实力高
可能是个C只是双一流
双一流指的是这个学校会在未来投入
所以都是他的重点学科方向好不好
这是双一流啊
然后再往下家长们硕博点
我们直播间有没有大概能去到的院校
只能去到中流211以下的
有没有去不了985
去不了顶尖的双呃
211院校的只能去到中流二一级以下的院校
大概可能在每个省份
因为每个省份是不一样
大概是在610往下吧
有没有有的可以有
有没有只能去到610往下的院校啊
这个时候如果你要去看学科评估
看双一流
发现哎呀没有
我查不到
或者他很差
这个时候你要看什么
看硕博点
尤其看博士点
硕士点我个人没有那么推荐
因为硕士点现在有点泛滥了啊
博士点要去看看
为什么他这个学校具有培养博士的资格
就意味着他这个学科一定很强
他有博导
它有大平台
它有经费支持
有各种各样的资源
所以看博士点
但是我要和你们说一下啊
我让你看这个学校博士点
不是让你去这个学校读博士啊
没有必要去双非区补本读博士啊
好不好
我只是说他这个学科很强
你本科在这读没有任何问题
为什么刚才我说从中流二幺以下再开始看呢
因为家长如果你是985
你看这个博士点
他哪个学科都有博士点啊
那你看他有什么必要吗对吧
只有当你到中流二以下
你发现哎固定的某几个学科才有博士点
你才能发现哦
这是他的强势学科好不好
所以啊这个博士你怎么看
去这个学校的研究生招生网上他都会公布的啊
好不好
好再往下啊
这个讲完了
然后各位站的各位同学
你们在今年填志愿的时候
有没有发现有很多学校新开了重点班
什么卓越班呐
什么英才班呐
什么领军班呢
什么拔尖班呐
什么荣誉班啊
什么人民班
什么特色学院啊
有没有发现有很多大类招生
什么叉叉大类叉叉类
叉叉实验班
发现没有
如果你发现的话怎么办
待会我会讲怎么去和招办聊他的招生政策
这个放在后面讲
但是我想提醒你一句啊
重点班不一定都是好的
为什么他有可能会给你虚假承诺啊
怎么去看待会儿啊
在这下一个部分
2020年怎么去看招生政策
招生招生政策
我会和你简单讲讲啊
好不好
然后第二点叫做大力招生
这个你们务必要关注了
大一招横折什么
你在大一选择专业时候呢
你并不能取代一个很固定的确定的专业
你只能选到什么叉叉
实验班
差实验班
叉叉类
而这个东西要在你进入大学以后
大一或者大二给你做专业分流
有可能会参考你的高考成绩
有可能会参考你大一成绩
但你叫同学如果要参与大力分流
你务必要去关注关注这个学校的大力分流政策
到底是怎么样的
听懂了吗
比如说如果你是一个高考弱省来的
他完全看大一的绩点
那你觉得你能拼得过高考强省的孩子
拿到热门专业的入场券吗
如果不行
那这个专业大类是不是就要谨慎
所以搞清楚啊
分流政策到底是什么
能接受这个大类
我再考虑
OK好再往下提个问题
我们直播间有没有家长的孩子打算
哎呦
学校什么无所谓
我只要先进去学
再差专业都无所谓
我大学里面转专业有没有的
扣一有没有这种想法
同学家长有没有有我有没有专业
啥无所谓啊
冷门专业我也能接受
反正你大学我能转专业啊
那家长如果你是这么考虑的话
那么请务必记住
不同的大学你的转专业的门槛是不可比的
怎么理解
有没有听到很多高校给你宣传
我们转专业零门槛
我们转专业转出无门槛
能自由选专业
但是你知道吗
转专业它分为转出加转入
转出无门槛
那不应该无门槛吗
我本身就不喜欢这个专业啦
你让我考到很高的分数啊
这不合理啊
你本来就应该没门槛
你转入有考核啊
你考的是什么笔试吗
面试吗
面试笔试考核什么
具体内容就怎么录取
你没说明白呀
对不对
把门槛搞清楚
第二这个很重要啦
叫比叫叫叫名额
叫同学把这个扣在评论
你们可能没听过
叫扩容比例四个字
扣在评论去扩容比例
什么叫扩容比例
我举个例子
比如说如果一个学校它的扩容比例在5%
也就意味着哎呀
我这个计算机我现在有100个人在就读
我允许我招五个人
100乘以5%
五个人
你转专业能进我们这个专业
那这个专业转专业也太难了吧
对不对
我给大家一个我自己认定的核心指标啊
一个学校如果要说转专业相对容易
必须扩容比例大于等于15%
否则比较容易
第二个名额看什么
去问问招办老师
去问问各种学长学姐
我们学校过去这两到3年
整体申请转专业的人有多少
最后成功转专业人有多少
最后这个成功比例有多少
如果你成功比例连70%都不到
你能叫转专业容易吗
嗯对不对
然后搞清楚怎么考核
最后这样同学请你们记住啊
如果你抱着刚才我们讲的这个说法
比如说你本科先进去啊
先不管读什么专业无所谓
我为了反战转专业
我请问如果你转专业没有成功
你到底能不能够接受这个风险
你能不能承担
如果能再这么考虑
OK好
怎么去打听
这个很简单
就各种各样的社交媒体
你们自己都都可以去打听啊
什么啊
某吧呀
某书啊
某音啊
阿B啊
对不对
哪儿都可以去打听啊
这个你们自己看啊
这个就不用我教了啊
但是这个呢我就稍微讲点小小情报啊
赵同学很多同学刚刚毕业
刚刚高中毕业
就是人呢情商也不太高
你过去的时候嘴巴甜一点
大家能不能把这两这四个字扣在评论区啊
录在嘴边
嘴巴甜一点诶
学长学姐
我是今年的高考生
我非常喜欢我们学校
我想请问一下你们学校转专业到底容不容易
有什么考核方式
能不能告诉我
感谢感谢佳佳同学
你收到这样的私信和你突然收到的私信
你们学校转专业如何劈头盖脸
就这么一句话
你更愿意回谁呀
在大学当中
非常多的资源都是你自己靠嘴问出来的
没有任何人会有义务告诉你这个资源到底在哪
我们这边有没有大学生在请大人告诉我
这是不是对的
在大学里面
很多资源是不是要靠你自己主动争取过来的
大学生是的
扣十
看到了吗啊好这转专业
然后这个部分就是今年很新的部分了
同意家长
我今年为什么要在院校当中加入这个环节
去聊聊2020年最新的招生政策
我请问你们最近有没有刷到非常多的推送
琳琅满目的推送
哎呦
我们学校今年有非常多招生亮点
我们给你几保一
我们给你五保六
我给你六保一
我们大类分流专业任选
我们可以任意转专业
我们百分之百保研
我们本研贯通培养
我们非常多中外合作项目
非常多
新专业给你非常多选择
我们有双学位
我们有我们有这个这个更多双学位
你可以无忧选专业
有没有发现好多学校都在宣传哦
发现了吗
那家长这东西真的是这样的吗
还是有没有坑啊
一个个来看
首先什么叫六保一
什么叫五保一
什么叫四保一
意味着你在填志愿的时候啊啊
无调剂省份没有这个疾保
一样都是有调剂审判
你们有调剂成份
比如说一个专业组
你不要你不要你不要那个填很多专业吗
好六保一的意思是你填满六个专业
我就给你保其中的任何一个专业
听起来很好对吗
但这同学我请问有坑没有两个坑
第一个坑前提是你填满六个专业
我给你保一个
但万一你填不满六个专业呢
你选不出来
那怎么办
比如说专业组里面有计算机
有电子信息
有自动化
有机器人
有电器好
第六个你挑不出来了
土木环境地质放在你面前
第二个你挑哪个
如果是这种保的
这个学校就太坏了
根本没有诚意
好不好
要谨慎
第二个还有什么坑
你知道不
结果明面上没写的很清楚
你私下去问老师
老师说哎呦
家长同学
我们学校要求是你满足条件
我给你六保一
也就是说你省牌要到多少名
你才能六保一
比如说我举个例子吧
他告诉你
你省牌要1万
我才给你六包一
你平时都没到1万位啊
平时你比1万位更多
我报你
我都是高的爆了
我本来以为我就可以到你学校任选专业啦
我给你
你给我六保一有没有诚意嘛
对不对
所以这两点啊是六保一五保一
四保一
你必须要关注点
如果这两点唉高校都没有给你耍耍心眼子
那么这个六百一五保一四保一
真的是很不错的选择
相当于自己能主动调剂
自己选择心仪专业啊
好不好
这第一个啊吉保一要怎么去看啊
家长夏同学
那个今天我们我们讲直播
我们讲这个课程
我们今天互动也不多
不像平时直播是竖屏直播
那么的生动形象
好不好
我讲课你们给我多互动互动
给我点点赞
给我点关注
点点点灯牌
我感觉没有这些数据
这讲课讲的有点没意思啊
好吧
我讲课你们帮我做做数据啊
感谢你们
今天这直播很干货吧
啥细节都有啊
好不好
点个关注
亮个灯牌
来来来
感谢你们
哈哈哈哈好
这第一个第二个告诉你嗯
大类分流专业任选
这样同学这句话听起来有没有点别扭
我本身如果你不是大类招生
你就是按正常的具体专业招生
我本身就是专业任选的
你现在给我搞一个大类专业招生以后
你给我说一个大类专业招生人选
好像是你施舍给我的一样
这本来就是我的权利
看到这个亮点
我真的气不打一处来对吧
我本身就自己能选到具体专业
你本身给我大力招生
招生以后
你告诉我大一专业任选
这是我的招生亮点
你现在哪了好
再往下任意转专业
家长这个就不用刷了
刚才讲过了
去考察考察他是不是有转入门槛案
去考察考察他的扩容比例
它的总体的成功比例
考核怎么形式
好不好好
再往下百分之百保研好
这个要关注关注了
加同学
如果你碰到一个学校招重点班
请务必要和招办老师去确认这个重点班
它重点在哪
他是百分之百保这百分之百
保这个这个这个这个保研吗
如果是百分之百保研
那么我的动态考核什么
你过程有没有动态淘汰进出
如果你会把人淘汰出去的话
那么你这个百分之百保研如何做承诺呢
你们现在正在保研
这批学生有多少是当年的原班人马
如果你有考核考核形式如何
是和具体的分数去做竞争
还是和人做竞争
我举个例子吧
比如说他告诉你
你如果满足80分
你就能够百分之百保研
家长这内卷吗
这不卷
很多孩子如果稍稍努力
你能达到这个分数就能保研
但如果他告诉你
你必须位于你们全班的前80%
你才能保研
那这个就相当恐怖了
为什么家长
比如说一个班一共20个人
19个人都考了100分
你考了99分
你也是最后一名
你也会被动态淘汰出去
能听懂这个逻辑吗
末位淘汰是很可怕的东西
会极大的加剧这个班的内卷程度
如果你担心孩子竞争力
那这样的淘汰标准你就要谨慎谨慎了
好了再往下哎呦
家长同学有没有关注啊
有学校和你说
我们这个重点班是本研贯通培养的
这位同学
我请问本研贯通培养是啥
是本硕贯通培养还是本博贯通培养呢
哎干什么啊
不要吵架
在干什么啊
不要吵架啊
不能吵架
吵架请出去
我们讲课讲的好好的
吵什么架
我讲课讲的正在镜镜头上捏在吵架
我要维护课堂秩序啊
不要吵架
吵架了
小队给我都禁言
好不好啊
不能吵架啊
来讲课了
讲课了
它既包括本研
又包括本硕
本博既考既包括本硕
又包括本博
因为硕士也是研究生
博士也是研究生
那这样的同学
我请问本博真的是好的贯通培养吗
真不一定
我们算笔账
本博什么意思
你本科毕业后直接攻读博士学位
你中间没有硕士这个阶段
5年本博攻读过程当中
相当于你4+59年拿一个本科加博士学历
但是博士真的那么好毕业的吗
博士大概率要言毕
假如你要言毕过后
第一年没满足毕业要求
第2年没满足毕业要求
第3年还没满足毕业要求
现在绝大部分的学校
博士最长的学业年限在8年
如果你8年还没有最后读
最后毕业的话
你就被学校劝退了
你就滚蛋了
所以你4+81共12年
你拿了一个本科
12年是个本科儿
再记下来
有些学校它相对而言呢是比较良心的
我允许你转硕士
但你转硕要在硕三时候转硕四才能毕业
那家的同学
你是4+48年才拿一个硕士学位啊
但是如果你普通读过硕士
读个专硕
读个读个学硕
你两年3年你就拿到博士学位喽
对不对
所以你相对而言时间成本又高了
所以本博我个人判断啊
特别是孩子在18岁这个时候去做决定
不算是一个好的决定
我会希望所有孩子
如果你在读研的时候要考虑本博贯通培养
最好在本科完整地经历过一次论文的发表
从选题立意到最后的做实验
跑数据
做回归到写论文
到去投文章
整体的修改反复
最后健康完整的经过这一段流程以后
再考虑我到底要不要读博士
这才是更加科学的方法
听懂了吗
所以啊问清楚老师
你们这个重点班本言贯通培养是本硕还是本博
我个人倾向以本硕优先
听懂了吗
好这是第一点
第二点
本研贯通培养要去关注另外一个指标
我请问这样的同学
您承不承认你去学习一个院校
你去学习一个
你去一个学校里面去读书
你本科在这个学校
你研究生想提升院校档次
比如说你本科在普本
你读研想去双一流
想去211
你本科在双一流
你读研想去211
你想去985
你本科在二一
你本科是末流985
你严重想去顶流九八对吗
如果是对的话
扣个一对不对对吗
我相信很少有同学
我本科硕士我都在一个平台
我觉得有点亏
是不是啊
但你这样的同学你知道吗
刚才讲的本研贯通培养
在很多学校不少的不允许你外保到其他学校
你读研只能留本校
所以你要去找这个学校去问清楚老师
你们这重点班允不允许外保
如果允许
OK多考虑
OK听到了吗啊好这个是本言贯通培养有什么
最后家长们
同学们有没有发现
今年从4月份开始
各个高校密集地开设了很多的中外合作项目
发现了扣一家长们
同学们
为什么
这个情况我不说了
一方面确实有挣钱的因素
另一方面
也有很多学校想保住自己普通批的招生录取位
次这个因素
但是如果你要报专业合作
要关注什么点呢
第一他的学制如何
4+03加12+2
前面这个只是你在国内的培养年份
后面只是在国外的培养年份
如果你要去国外的话
你要考虑他的生活费
那不单单仅仅只是一个学费的哟
这考虑清楚啊
学制第二允不允许保研
很多学校中外合作
保研率相比普通批没有那么多
第三考虑一下中外合作整体的花销
不仅仅要看刚才有说了啊
整体学校在国内的学费
你要考虑在国内的学费
整体在国外的生活费
特别是如果你要出国出个一两年
这一两年尤其在英美生活成本很高的
你可能打底要拿个100万出来
那如果这样的话
那你这中文合作读起来那意义就不大了哟
好不好
中外合作在什么时候才对你来说有性价比
能给你的同学
能给你的孩子带来院校层次的本质提升
什么意思
molly985能去中绿
中流985能到顶流
211能去985
双一流能去211
普版能去211
如果你是普本院校的这个中外合作
我个人建议意义不甚大
好不好
好在同学
这就是今年我们最新增加的部分啊
2020年的招生政策
因为有很多学校现在发了非常多招生亮点
你们看的琳琅满目
但是这个东西怎么去识别高校的招生轨迹
我把核心要点全部给你讲完了
好不好
再往下
那在哪可以去了解一下真实学校的评价
这个渠道呢
第一你自己能够去接触到的
你们本校本高中的学长学姐
第二刚才给你展示的我自己做的那个网站框框
大学第三大学生活质量直被第四
各类社交平台
刚才讲了什么小某书啊
啊某音啊
阿B啊啊等等某吧都都可以去找啊
这是你能够找到啊
在读学长学姐的相关的地方
好不好啊
各位学位上
然后我们现在刚刚讲完第三个部分
怎么去挑选院校啊
老师请问机器人工程能读吗
机器人哎
站站长站长
那我把这个问题讲完
我们就开始讲课啊
你这问题问的很好
因为机械今年大涨
今年机器人肯定大涨好不好
因为我们从春晚来看
我们从各种那个呃直播间
从各种那个短视频里面看机器人
机械机器人他的趋势很很高
但家人们如果你家孩子是高分段的话
机器人工程能读
他更加偏向于智能人形
机器人偏向于巨神智能
但如果你是中低分段啊
比如说如果你是普一本
今年不能读
我讲讲我的观点
机器人工程是一个比较
它不是一个老
它不是一个很新的专业
他是个老专业
2013年就有了
当时的培养
不是偏向于工业机器人
当时的哦不当时培养不是偏向于智能机器人
是偏向于工业机器人和服务机器人的
特别是工业机器人
工业机器人
你只能读机械工程才能入行吗
不是的
你读机械
你读电气
你读你
你读电子信息
你读纯自动化
你都能入行
但今年可预计的是
机器人工程它一定会涨分
那既然如此的话
你为什么要抱着如此高的分数
如此低的性价比买入机械工程呢
我个人认为性价比不高
所以说这样嘛
我我我一直讲到一一讲的观点
高分段今年机械工程能读中低分段没有意义
性价比贼低啊
啊家人们这个专业部分我们就我们就不要说了
如果您对专业真的很感兴趣
明天我会在直播间
我们上午就单独讲个话题
好不好
就是所有的热门专业
高分段
中分段
低分段哪些适合读
我会把我的判断全部和你说明白
好不好
家人们
如果你感这个兴趣的这个这个话题感兴趣的话
你可以点个关注
明天早上八点钟来我们直播间啊
好到点了
我们接着讲下面的问题了
到点了到点了到点了
好家人们
接下来
我们来真真正正踏入志愿填报的实操环节了
但踏入之前我们要先做个思考
因为这涉及到后面的志愿填报的排序
这很重要啊
首先各位同学
国家填报志愿
你必须首先基于你自己的个人条件做思考
第一你经济条件到底如何
经济状况到底如何
如果家境很一般
家长同学就不要学那种虚头巴脑的专业了
什么天文呐
什么社会学啊
这种纯科研类导向的
你孩子未来是要就业
是要挣钱的人
要务实一点好不好
但如果你经济条件很好
那无所谓
孩子本身进大进大学以后
他就是为了为了能够发扬自己
各种各样的特长的
我去寻找自己的
对不对
这我们读大学目的不一样
所以家人们首先把首先把经济扣在评论区啊
把经济扣在评论区啊
经济扣在评论区
第二个你的家庭资源如何
家里有没有那种完全能靠得上的亲戚
我觉得是靠得上啊
你真的能找到那种
不是那个填志愿的时候突然出现的
七大姑八大姨那种
是不靠谱的
你们经常能联系
能切实帮到孩子
在入行的时候
这样能利用到的人脉资人脉资源
那你可以利用利用
但是如果你要利用这种人脉资源
它的前提是孩子本人对这个行业是不排斥的
我举个例子吧
比如说有这样说
哎呀孩子你要么就读交通运输
要么就读铁道机车
反正我们在铁路系统里面有人好
如果同学本人对近铁路系统不排斥
那没问题
这个家庭资源那就O但如果孩子本人排斥
那就算了啊
这个就不要考虑了啊
家庭资源
这第二点
第三点
成绩分段啊
把高中低扣在评论区啊
家人们高分段叫98511
顶尖的普版中分段叫普一本
普二版
高中低哪个分数段扣在评论区
我讲过
如果你是高分段
那根据自己的条件来选就可以了
如果想挣钱
理科生嘛
优选新工科
文科生嘛
有选法学经管嘛
对不对
但如果是中分段的孩子
文科生你你就不用太在乎什么专业
本身专业本身除了法学都没有壁垒
给我优选院校
给我优选城市就可以了
但理科生的话
如果是男生
我会建议你考虑务实的
比如说机械啊
电气啊
能源动力相关的专业
如果是女生就有点难办了
中分的女生
因为她一般会有些偏科
而偏科以后导致一些工科呢她选不了
这时候我会有点建议
如果物理化学还不错
可以选材料
如果生化比较不错
你可以选那种好生学的生化相关专业
什么化学啊
生物啊
食品啊
农学啊
我没说这些专业还包还包括药学
我没说这专业就业多好
就业真的很一般
甚至有点差
但是他比较好
升学容易读上研究生
你未来可以凭借院校层次来吃饭
如果中分段的理科生
女孩子
你比如说你数学还不错
能及格
那么经管类专业是可以的
至于低分段同学给我学实在的手艺类专业
好不好
文科生也给我学理工科实在手艺专业什么
比如说什么啊
铁道机车呀
那种偏电的
什么机电一体化呀啊
什么电梯维修啊
什么弱电方向啊
都是可以的
再加上可能如果你能吃苦的话
康复啊
口腔啊
这种可以考虑考虑好不好
不要学什么虚头巴脑的经管类专业
我低一分段
谁让你管理啊
对不对
学实在手艺类专业啊
好这第三个
第四个同学问问你自己
到底未来有没有进一步进取的能力和野心
我提个问题
如果你读本科
未来打算读研的扣一
如果你读专科
未来打算专升本的扣一
如果你就停在本专业啦
比如本专科毕业以后
我就要就业的扣二
哎呦这么多啊
这么多在升学的吗
有点超出我的意料啊
这么多扣一的那同学
如果你要扣一的话
那请务必搞清楚你未来到底有没有考学能力了
意愿都有啊
因为真真正正能够做到比较好上岸的
比如说你本科硕升升研究生
你的考研率对不对
你的保研率
你专科升本科专升本
那你能不能好好的在这个环境里面
说实话专科环境也没有太好
很少有人会有这个拼劲
你能不能在我说的直白点
出淤泥而不染
能够摒弃旁边的环境来
心无旁骛地去做升学
这点很重要
如果你学历就停在本专科了
你就你就不要去学
那种什么虚头巴脑的
一定要读研才有好去处的方向
比如说尽管哈哈哈哈哈
比如说当今时代的计算机
OK好
你必须要认清自己的基础条件
未来在择业
未来在选专业的时候才会有更好的方向感
好不好
不同人他选择专业的方向其实不太一样好
那么接下来我们就要讲一个很重要的话题了
在填报志愿的时候
永恒的焦点叫做专业
学校和地区哪个更重要
家长同学扣在评论区
你觉得人更重要
你目前觉得哪个更重要
专业院校的地区
谈谈我的观点
不同分数段和不同专业
它的重点其实不太一样
首先确定专业
请各位这样记住
我让你确定的不是某一个具体的专业
不是说比如说我就我就定在机器人工程了
我就定在电子信息工程了
定专业的方向叫做定两个
一个叫定专业范围
比如说我如果要读电子信息
那是不是整个电子信息大类
比如电子信息工程
电子科学与技术
通信工程
信息工程等等等等
我都能接受
注意要定专业的范围
不要定某一个具体的专业
第二点定专业的下限
这点很重要
下限和底线
为什么
这涉及到一个一个概念来
我们有调剂省份
你们可以扣个一啊
有调剂省份
老高考和专业组
招这个招招考的这个相关的省份
你们可以扣个一
无调剂省份没有这个问题啊
有调剂省份
你们是不是经常听到的概念叫做干净的专业组
何为干净的专业组
意思就是说这个专业组里面的每一个专业
我都全部能够接受
但家长这个东西是千人千面的吧
每个人都不一样吧
没有任何一个软件
没有任何app能告诉你这个专业组他干净
只能你自己确定我到底能接受
专业底线和下限到底在哪
我举个例子
家长同学现在有个专业组
专业组里面有哪些专业呢
计算机科学与技术
软件工程
自动化
机器人工程
电子信息工程好
如果孩子就打算只读新工科
这个专业组是不是特别干净
没有任何问题
刚才讲的全是新工科
但如果这个专业组里面突然多了一个专业
叫做机械工程
那我请问这个专业组对这个学生而言
他现在干净吗
是不是就不干净了
因为他只想读新工科
机械是传统工科
对不对
好现在换另外一个孩子
那个孩子说可以
我的专业下限我能定在机械
机械
我能够接受
那么这个专业组对第二个孩子而言
他干净吗
他就干净了
所以啊确认清楚你的专业底线到底在哪里
这叫定专业啊
第二个叫定学校
定义学校很简单
因为很多直播间会你塑造焦虑
说哎呀我们中国这么多这么多学校
你所有学校把什么保研率啊
升学率啊
学科实力啊
呃这个老师的师资情况你都去了解一下
以后你没有这么多精力
家长没有必要
因为孩子他能够在这个位次之下
你上下浮动的一些位次
你能挑的院校也就那么二三十所
特别是如果你能到最顶尖的院校
你到985
你能跳的院校也就那么也就那么几所了
没有那么多的
你不用了解那么多的院校的啊
所以啊确定的位次
圈定你的学校的区间就可以了
然后如果你要挑地区
地区意味着什么
第一我会把我们中国的相关的城市呢划分
这不是我这不是我划分的
这是那个啊
应该是第一财经吧
还是哪个机构
反正我忘了
每一年都会去推出我们中国的一线新线二线
三线四线的城市的名单
这个是2026年最新的名单
如果你在挑城市时候
你肯定奔着越好城市去越好
因为这地方它有产业
有资源
有配套
有交通基础设施
在这边你能有更好的生活和就读体验度
也能更容易找到工作
OK这是我们对于城市的排序
而且城市不仅仅是你要去看它的城市的层级
你要看什么呢
还要看什么
还要看你的气候
因为比如说因为我我自己就是南方小孩
就当年哦呃你们不要说我凡尔赛啊
但是是事实啊
当年我能通过提前批上北大
然后最后呢在正常批次里面
在复旦和中国人民大学当中纠结
都是最好的专业
都是经管类专业
是文科生
当时我为什么考虑是复旦没有去人大
是因为我自己
因为当年我们212011年的时候
北方的沙尘暴的那个新闻很严重
我自己是南方小孩
所以我不太想去北方
所以最后我选择去了复旦啊
是这样的情况
真的是这样情况
这是我很重要的决策因素啊
呵所以气候很重要
气候很重要
然后第二个饮食也蛮重要的
特别是我们有没有那种完全不吃辣的同学
如果你完全不吃辣的话
你去什么江西啊
去什么湖南呐
去什么川渝啊
哼那你这个饮食你可能就无福消受了啊哈哈哈
什么叫哎你干什么
重庆也算南方啊
秦岭淮河线以南都是南方啊
好不好啊
包括文化
比如说我们有很多同学喜欢文化娱乐活动
比如你喜欢文娱
那什么长沙呀
那很适合你
如果你喜欢什么二次元
喜欢漫展
那上海很适合你
对不对
这个你要考虑考虑
然后基建基建什么叫做基础交通啊
基础设施建设
像什么交通啊啊地铁啊
各种交通网络和公共服务设施都叫做基建
这个会影响你在这个城市的生活幸福度啊
然后还有你的视野
你在大城市里面更容易碰到大型的活动
你能接触到新的资源
顶级的这种现代化产业能帮你打开视野
呃
这样的同学
我不知道你认不认可孩子去大学里面读
大学读专业
一方面我们确确实实续学本领
拿文凭
但另一方面
去大学也是帮助我们打开视野的一个过程
特别是对于在高考之前
不是位于省会计划单内
是直辖市的孩子
您认可吗
我很认可这句话
很多孩子真真正正大人生开始成长
就是他进入大学开始的好
再往下啊
产业很重要
产业对应两个东西
一个叫实习
一个叫做就业
尤其是你要读什么呢
比如说你要读什么经管法学啊
新闻啊
文科在包括理工科里面什么计算机啊
非常吃你的实习资源
所以如果你去一些啊
我这个这个说文明一点啊
就是产业配套没有那么发达的城市的话
相对而言你可能会失望
你本科没办法积累如此多的实习资源
OK好不好
所以这就是城市
你可能又要考虑一些因素好
再接下来为了去搞清楚我们怎么去去划分专业
院校和地区的排序
我们还要去划分几个情况来
我们还是做个调查
我们直接永恒的话题啊
高中低分段高分段扣高中分段
扣中低分段的扣低高分段叫985
叫中流以上的211
普通二本和政策照顾性的211
这样每一个分数段你在考虑这三大因素的时候
它的优先度不一样
对于高分段的同学
记住肯定是院校大于专业的
为什么我们举个很极端的例子
清华北大
中国独一档的高校
确实华东五校也很强
复旦交大呃
那个浙大等等都很强
但是他们和清华北大确实就有壁垒的
如果你分数层次越高
院校层次提升带来的差距会呈指数级别的提升
但同意家长
我请问
如果到中低分段
你分数差个十分位次
差个一两千名
这两个学校在未来就业的时候
他的就业有本质区别吗
是不是没有
我再重复一遍
在中低分段你收分差个十分位次
差个一两千名的学校
为了在就业的时候
他的区别有本质区别吗
没有
所以在中低分段应该是专业优于院校的
听懂了吗
这是不同分数段怎么去考虑
然后我们来看学科
来再做调查
我们直播间如果要去读人文社科
经管艺术的同学扣一读理科
工科
农科同学扣二
读医科的同学扣三嗯
首先人文社科经管艺术
他的专业壁垒并不高
你本科读个新闻
你未来能做文字编辑吗
你可以
你本科读个中文
你未来能做记者吗
你可以
所以让你吃饭的是院校平台
除非你要毛思法学
法学也有行业壁垒
是因为规定了你只能读了法学以后
你才能考法考
那如果你是Q2的
未来要读理工理理科
工科农科的同学
专业大于院校
因为专业是你师范的手艺
我举个很不恰当的例子
家长同学
你本科如果读计算机
你读研想转土木
虽然没人这么没有人这么考虑啊
但但我举个例子啊
你本科读计算机读研
想读土木
你本科学了很多的编程
学了很多计算机408的课程
你读研转转转学力学东西啊
可不可能转过去很难的
但如果反过来你本科学个土木
你读研转计算机
那也很难呐
你本科学的全是力学
你要学大量的编程
你要学大量的这种代理工科
学大量的计算机
408课程好不好
所以理工农科他专业壁垒是挺高的
那么专业要大于院校
而如果是扣于三的同学
家长同学请记住啊
对于医科最重要的是地区
你一定要讲究地头蛇属性
什么意思
除非你能去到
比如说北大协和复旦
上交
这四所几乎是全国最顶的一科类的院校
你尚且还可能做到全国横着走
其实也不太能
除此以外
很多地方别人不认985211
只认我们当地的地头蛇院校
我举个例子吧
比如黑龙江的哈尔滨医科大学
辽宁的中国医科大学
江苏的南京医科大学
重庆的重庆医科大学和陆军军医大学
云南的昆明医科大学等等等等
他们是9821吗
不是的
但是他们在本上就有更高的认可程度好
那么我们再合在一起
亲爱的同学
刚才是分开讲的
现在合在一起讲
来直播间长同学跟着我一起互动啊
如果你是人文社科经管艺术的高分段扣一
如果你是人文社科经管艺术的中低分段扣二
如果你是理工农科的高分段扣三
如果你是理工农科的中低分段扣四
如果你属于属于读医科的科
五一科不分不分分数段啊
好一个个讲啊
现在合在一起讲了
合在一起讲了
如果你是扣一的很简单
高分段院校优先
人文社科经管艺术也是院校优先
所以扣一的同学家长学校大于专业大于地区
为什么地区放最后一位
因为高分段以外基本要持续升学
你为了拿到更高的保研资格
拿到更高的保研数据
你有的时候反而要牺牲院校档次
这点能听懂吧
所以扣一同学学校大于专业大于地区
而如果是扣二的同学
学校本身也没那么重要
专业本身也没那么重要
那么什么最重要
地区最重要
所以Q2同学地区放在首位
至于专业和学校哪个放在第二位都行
看你的需求
因为在这边你才更容易有实习
更容易就业呀
那如果是Q3的同学呢
这个就比较纠结了
高分段学校重要
理工农科专业更重要
所以哪个放在第一位
看您的个人需求
城市地区肯定放最后一位
英语高分段
你未来持续升学
你为了拿到更高的保研率
你要牺牲院校哦
你要牺牲城市的
所以城市放最后一位啊
如果是扣四的同学
中低分段理工农科很简单
中低分段专业优先
理工农科也是专业优先
所以专业一定放在首位
而城市和学校哪个放第二位呢
我个人认为把城市放在第二位
因为中低分段在这里你更能有找工作的机会
所以呀扣四的同学
我的答案是专业大于地区大于院校
至于扣五
刚才说了
学医地区第一位
对不对
地区放首位
那专业和学校为什么专业放第二位呢
因为如果你未来想做医生
你只能读以下这四类专业
临床医学大类
口腔医学大类
中西医
中医学大类和中西医结合大类
不然的话你未来都不能做医生
不能考执医资格证
不能有处方权啊
所以专业放第二位
然后学校放第三位
听懂了吗啊
家长同学
这就是你在填志愿的时候
这三个要素对于不同分数段的孩子
对于不同专业背景的孩子怎么去做一个思考
好累啊好累
你就不要听了
好不好
学啥不累
真的不要说了啊
你说了好几遍了啊
哈贾同学
我觉得今天的内容还是很有干货的吧
我尽量在调动自己的情绪啊
因为学知识本身就是枯燥的啊
如果你觉得讲的好的话
能不能点个关注吧
哎呀谢谢你们点个关注
亮亮灯牌
点点赞吧
好像今天直播间的数据很一般啊
讲的这么干货
直播间才才20万赞
连30万都没有
能不能点点赞啊
谢谢你们
好歹今天我们晚上人很多
告诉你们个数据吧
家人们
同学们
今天晚上我们直播间最高在线人数1万6000人
这么好的直播间不值得点个关注吗
啊好再往下讲啊
再往下讲
没讲完这个部分
各位站各位同学
如果您是我的老粉
新粉肯定不知道
老粉肯定知道啊
我是一个非常希望孩子能在高考填志愿的时候
给你保留更大可能性
走宽口径路径的人
老粉应该知道
所以说当你没有任何的思路
或者你做完志愿填报以后
你假如想要保留更多可能性
希望你注意一下容错的空间
家长来第一个
我请问咱们有没有同学
有没有家长哎呀
现在专业定不了
定不了哇
孩子的性格没有确定下来
而且也没了解这么多社会现实
我不知道专业学什么
我先奔院校层次吧
有没有扣个一
有没有
我就先背院校
专业是啥
无所谓
进大学了再说
搞不定了
那填志愿太麻烦了
这专业这么多
我怎么搞得定吗
好这样同学如果是这样的话
我建议啊优先选择综合类大学
综合类大学它的学科门类齐全
你在里面能接触到大部分学科门类的同学
而且你有机会转专业
甚至快呃
跨专业保研或者考研
那哪些叫综合类大学呢
文理类的大学像复旦呐
像北大呀
像南开呀
南京大学啊
理工类大学也算综合类大学
上交啊
清华等等等等
师范类大学也叫综合类大学
但从师范之后
财经政法农林民族一棵一般都是专门类大学
它里面的学科门类并没有那么齐全
所以如果孩子这样情况的话
我建议优先选择前三大类院校
尤其前两类文理和理工师范类院校
一般来说工科建设会比较的缺乏
OK啊某某科技科技是理工类大学吗
啊好再往下
如果各位同学
各位这样
你未来是打算读研
你的学历层次并不久
只是停留在本科的话
我会建议你优先选择基础类的专业
什么叫基础学专业
首先第一个你本科可以选择纯理学专业
什么纯数学
纯物理
但是注意啊
纯数纯物学习难度极高是极高啊
如果孩子啃不下来
那会很麻烦
所以一定要注意他未来到底能不能转向
以及学习难度
需要你做好大学规划
这第一个
第二个各位站过同学
什么叫做基础类专业
我这边讲过很多次
你去翻一翻中国本科专业目录
每一个大类啊
他不是都有010203都有编号吗
他的编号越靠前
他又越是基础专业
比如说计算机类里面的计算机科学与技术
和软件工程
一个是零一
一个是零二
电子信息带里面的电子信息工程
电子科学技术和通信工程
它是010203
比如说自动化大类里面的自动化
它是零一
电气大类里面的电气工程及其自动化
他们都是基础专业
都是妈妈
都是爸爸
你未来读研读这个大里面所有细分专业都OK
转过去的逻辑非常顺畅
听懂了吗
所以啊如果决定深造基础类专业
它的优先度相对是比较高的
好
再往下家人们
我请问如果你要读那种小口径专业
你能不能读什么叫小口径专业
我举个例子吧
在计算机大里面有个专业
叫什么叫做虚拟现实技术
叫做区块链工程
我的天哪
这么怎
这本科专业搞得如此细分干什么
如果家里真的有资源
有人卖
同学
你也确定了
我以后一定会投身这个行业
那这个小口径专业你就读吧
但如果不是的话
就不要选择这种小口径专业了
我的天哪
你未来转转方向挺难的
别了啊
这也太小对视的啊
真的有这种专业啊
哈好啦
同学校长
如果你在本专科阶段的话
我几乎不太推荐所有的复核和新兴专业
什么叫复合专业呢
A加BB加C
C加D
A加B加C加D
我举个例子吧
家长同学
我们今年有没有关注低空经济的同学
有的扣一去年有个专业叫做低空技术与工程
横空出世
这个专业就属于交叉门类
这个专业是啥
航空航天加电子加信息加自动化
加交通运输加管理科学与工程里面的运筹方向
再加遥感
我的天哪
你就读到本专科
你读一个这么杂的专业啊
你学的下来跟额说话
我没点
你怎么可能学得下来呢
对不对
你一定要读研深造了啊
憋了啊呵呵
所以啊个人没那么建议
如果你实在要读好不好
在大学里面把握相关的就读侧重点
读研再继续深造
往这个方向去深根
否则你本科啥都学
啥都学容易
啥都学不精
样样通样样松万金
我说的是你啊
好不好
复合专业
然后新兴专业家人们
我个人也一般不推荐来
张同学有没有听过一个专业叫做聚生智能
2026年的新专业
有没有听过聚生智能干嘛呢
呃在今时今日的语境里面
就是造智能人形机器人的呵
今年新开了九所院校
你九所呃
上交浙大
北航
北理哈工大
西交东北大学
北邮和南京航空航天大学
哇
同学讲
这不都是顶流的工科
98211吗
对没问题
他们是有培养基础的
这几个有哪些
刚才讲的
比如说聚生智能哎家长同学
我要打个前提啊
什么叫居称智能
人形智能机器人对吧
它就相当于是人工智能加机器人工程
那么请问人工智能是啥
不就是计算机自动化加统计吗
机器人工程是啥
是不是自动化加机械
而且你机械工程有信号传输
有电机控制
所以要加电子信加
机加电子信息加自动化加机械加电器
但家长刚才讲的这些98521
卡了吗
卡了怎么回事
现在好了吗
现在好了是吧啊哦吓我一跳啊
啊好好好
那行啊
那行了
卡了一下啊
还好还好嗯好
就讲课
那我请问刚才讲的这些9821
是不是都可以吗
OK没问题
他们工科都很强
蛋酱同学
如果明年填志愿的话
你发现有不少的普通本科
新增加聚深证这个专业方向
我请问他们是突然就具备智能人形
机器人的培养基础了吗
是不是没有
所以这种新兴专业你如果真的去读的话
你大概率就是那个小白鼠
我个人不主动推荐
但是你们有没有发现交叉学科已成趋势
今年甚至把交叉学科
单独拎成了一个单独的学科门类
而未来这个趋势会进一步的去延伸
那家长们
同学们
咱们去思考
如果真的要学记住两点
第一做好大学规划
抓住你在本专科的学习重点
第二一定要持续升学
这是我对大家的核心的提醒
好家长们
同学们刚刚又讲了几10分钟了啊
我们再简单休息一下
前面所有的知识铺垫全部完啦
工具专业院校志愿填报的选择逻辑
在之后下个环节就是手把手带你填一次志愿
填报了
先休息2分钟
现在正好呃8.44
然后我们休息到8.47吧
好不好
有什么问题扣在评论区啊
有没有问题扣在评论区啊
嗯感觉没有说够啊
听的很爽
哎家长没点实力
今天能够全网1.6万人在线啊
哼
好不好
没点实力
能全网1.6万在线吗
啊哈哈哈哈
然而今天有回放吗
今天当然有回放
现象如此之大啊
肯定必须得有回放的啊
嗯而智能制造适合女生吗
读研适合
如果不读研的话
没有那么适合
因为智能制造是什么专业呢
它是相当于是机械的一个新工科方向
其实他也杂入了很多方向
我给你举个例子吧
我经常举的一个例子是智能制造
可以把类比于机械加计算机加自动化
加工业工程
所以如果是去普本的话
我个人不推荐98521
你读了以后也一定要读硕读博
否则也没有那么推荐啊
自从认识老师以后就没间断过听课啊
那那你会间断了
嘿嘿马上高爆就结束了
哈哈高爆结束以后啊
这哎家人们
同学们
高爆结束以后
你也逃不开我
7月底等孩子的录取结果出来以后
专业院校定了以后
我们直播间讲大学规划
而且我的账号里面很多的
很多的视频都是讲大学规划的
怎么考公
怎么考研
怎么保研
怎么做大学规划
大一大二大三路径如何
那以后你大学以后也离不开我的
特别是我们同学啊
你在各个平台一搜诶
怎么突然一入框框
我这视频哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
老师经管这个专业难吗
这个经管这个专业如果读本科不难
如果读硕的话
读硕读博对数学要求相对比较高
老师女孩或男孩学护理如何啊
首先我们谈谈护理教本身这个专业
护理本身这个专业是一个学历压缩的专业
是怎么去理解
高分段读护理性价比极低
但中低分段读护理
只要你能吃苦
找工作难度并不算太高
所以这是一个学校层次越高
学历层次越高越亏
但学历层次越低呃
还相对比较赚的一个专业
这第一个第二个啊
讲男生和女生性别啊
其实男护比女护更吃香
这个是业内的共识
但是因为男护在医院里面有很多体力活儿
所以男户的离职率挺高的
但男护真的挺好找工作
老师自动化是复合专业吗
自动化是万旧专业
不算复合专业
自动化是有自己本源的学科的
哎作为小做
我们做个小小互动啊
家长同学们知道自动化读研叫什么吗
自动化读研的一级学科叫什么
他他有自己的一级学科哦
自动化读研一级学科叫什么
告诉我知道吗
有没有知道的
自动化读研的一级学科叫什么名字啊
不知道啊
精密仪器啊
呵呵呵啊
我们某音和某批号打的人比较多啊
控制控制工程
你自动化就是做控制的
做工业流程控制
做导航制导控制的
呃老师您能讲能不能具体讲每个专业的适合唉
这样我讲过很多次嘞
诶再做个预报啊
因为今天我们讲知识填报实操
我们不能讲这么细呀
家长同学
如果你们非常关心各个热门专业
高分段
中分段
低分段到底更适合哪些孩子读
要读它需要具备什么样的素质和要求的话
明天早上八点钟我们讲这个话题可不可以啊
明早八点直播间见啊
比如计算机每个分数段怎么去考虑电子信息
每个分数段怎么考虑自动化
每个分数段怎么考虑
法学
尽管每个分数段怎么考虑啊
呃电器每个分数怎么考虑好不好
明天早上啊
明天早上早上八点钟啊
嗯明早八点不见不散
好讲课讲课讲课讲课了
家长们
同学们讲课讲课讲课
接下来思路一定要跟着我走啦
我们接下来大概用接近可能50分钟的时间来
手把手带你完成一次志愿填报
集中注意力开始
首先讲这个之前
我们要先去界定一下不同省份的区别
来新疆西藏的同学扣一北京
上海天津海南
江苏福建湖南湖北广东黑龙江
广西吉林
安徽甘肃
江西河南
四川
山西内蒙
云南陕西宁夏扣二
浙江山东重庆
河北
辽宁
贵州青海扣三
这样同学123
你们分别的志愿填报的模式是不一样的
首先老高考模式是最简啊
不是最最简便
最传统的模式就是呃院校的模式
你每个志愿填报单元是一个院校
而Q2的同学你们是院校加专业组
你填的每个单元是一个专业组
你在专业组里面要填具体的几个专业好不好
而Q3的同学你们没有调剂
扣一块二都有调剂啊
Q3是没有调剂的
你们每个填报单元是确定的一个院校加专业
记住123
家长们
同学们
待会儿我讲每个填报的时候
我会讲扣一扣二扣三的省份
你们对号入座好不好
来往下来
那我们讲完分布以后填志愿
你必须搞懂的一个概念叫做平行志愿
来把平行两个字扣在评论区
平行志愿他一共有三个标准
记一下啊
很很重要啊
这关系到你们怎么去理解志愿填报的
整个的录取过程
一共三个词
分数优先
遵循志愿和一次投档
什么意思
来这样同学分数优先的意思是哎我们你本省啊
有很多考生
对不对
每个考生都有你确定的一个位次
然后我们省教育考试院在投档的时候
在检索的时候会按照位次做个排序
哎我先检索分数高的
比如说先看一这个第一名
再看第二名
再看第三名
再看第四名
按照分数一个一个往下检索
这叫分数优先
第二个什么叫遵循志愿
就是我在检索每个考生他的选择的时候
我先看他的一专业
再看他的二专业
再看他的三专业
这叫遵循自愿
那什么叫一次投档
这个就很关键了
我们要分无调剂省份和有调剂省份
首先扣三的
各位同学
各位家长无条件计价
你们投档的时候
你投了就投了
因为你没有调剂
除非你因为单科成绩或者自身的体检条件限制
一般来说你就被录取了
但是对于有调剂的各位省份的同学家长
假如你的是你的档案被这个学校踢走了
你面临的问题是什么
你面临的是你这个专业组里面
肯定还有空余的名额
不然不可能给你提早
对不对
但是假如你填的所有专业里面全部都站满了人
但你还不服从调剂
注意啊
一个批次只有一次投档机会
因为一次投档
你后面的志愿还算数吗
不算数了
听懂没有就不算数流
所以你有可能本科只能去征集志愿
如果你征集志愿还没上的话
你如果是新高考
本科就要调专科了
所以无调剂审犯是刚才扣三的同学
有调剂是扣一扣二的同学好
听懂了吗
我感觉你没听懂没关系
我们用一个例子来和你去看一看这个例子啊
去年也有啊
来同学长问这个例子啊
等一下啊
等一下展示不全呢
怎么回事
OK啊
这个展示全了
哦不行
这个也展示不全
往下lie拉
好同学家长来我们念一下题干啊
有这样一个题干
已知全省有且仅有四个考生
这四个考生都考了相关的分数
比如说一哥考了680分
夫人考了672分
齐哥考了670分
框框考了668分
诶
怎么头像挡住了是吧
等一下啊
马上
OK啊
这就没挡住了
好
现在呢只有清华大学和华中科技大学来招生了
清华大学有且仅有一个电器和一个土木的指标
华科有且仅有一个计算机和一个机
械的招生指标
而我们四个人他的模式都是一模一样的
我们都是一志愿填的清华专业
医填的电气专业
二填的土木
我们专业我们一志愿都服从调剂
而二志愿都填的华科的计算机
第二专业没有填
然而且不服从调剂
好家长同学来给大家半分钟30秒
请问我们四个人会怎么去安排最后的志愿
30秒想想啊
30秒30秒啊
30秒怎么安排啊
怎么安排
按照平行志愿来来来做数的话啊
怎么安排好
我们已经过去20秒了
还有十秒啊
好还有五秒倒计时啊
543210好
来一个个来
先是分数优先
所以一哥先选看一哥检索哦
一哥你是全省第一名的
算全省只有四个考生
哈哈你全省第一名好检索你的一志愿
一志愿里面遵循你的志愿
先看你的专业一
你是清华电气
清华电气现在没有人
你去一哥去了
清华电器好
再来分数优先
第二名检索夫人夫人哎呦
一志愿里面他不是有两个指标吗
对不对
现在里面只有一个人进去了
那还有一个指标
对不对
夫人就投进去了
好解锁他的志愿专业一嗯
电器里面有人了啊
一哥在里面
你不能去啊
专一二你选土木好
可以土木你去了
那夫人就去了清华的土木好
第三名看齐哥
首先检索他专这个一志愿
一志愿我本身就两个名额
里面已经有两个人占坑了
一志愿没有坑位了
你去不了
我只能检索你的二志愿
好看一下志愿
华科计算机没有人吗
对齐哥去了华科的计算机好
确定了啊
然后检索三呃
这个第四名
第四名就是这个全省最后一名空话
虽然这次的考生考很高
最后一名啊
一志愿两个名额都叫满人
所以我们只能看二志愿
二志愿有两个指标
本身就有两个指标
对不对
华科有两个指标吗
他有计算机和机械两个指标
但目前只有一个人在里面
就是齐哥
还有一个空余
好
先把他投到华科里面去了
华科来看哦
你的专业都是计算机啊
不行
计算机里面有人了
不要不要然看空框
你怎么没有专业二呢
再看啊
你不服从调剂啊
那不好意思啊
虽然我们有个机械的空余指标
但你不服从调剂
你机械又没选上去
那算了算了
框框你反正不爱我们
填志愿是一个双向奔赴的过程
所以框框只能去参与征集志愿
如果征集志愿都没上的话
那么框框只能本科调专科了
所以最后怎么安排
一哥去了清华
电器夫人去了清华土木齐哥去了华科
计算机框框征集志愿或者滑档
掉到下个批次恐不恐怖啊
太恐怖了吧
所以服从条件要填上啊
一定要填上
待会会讲啊
好再往下再来
同学们
如果你还不能理解
我们用第二个例子来和你再做解释
因为很多同学在这个时候有点没太理解啊
所以我会放第二个例子
帮你把平行志愿给他加深好
所有题干都不变
现在突然时来运转
清华多了一个数学的招生指标
其他所有内容都不变啊
都不变都不变
就就清华多了一个数学招生指标
那我请问最后志愿怎么安排
给大家演示30秒吧
好不好
30秒啊
最后志愿怎么样来
就清华多了一个数学招生指标
30秒啊
已经过去十秒了呀
啊这怎么安排啊
怎么安排这个志愿表啊
框框还是滑档了
框框还是选不上
坤哥活过来啦
坤哥活过来没有啊
好了
最后五秒钟啊
来543210好揭晓答案
刚才说我还滑档的人没有理解清楚
好好听
来分数优先先检索
一哥没问题
一哥仍然去了清华电器
解锁第二名
夫人没问题
夫人仍然去了清华的土木
但是变量来了
因为清华有三个招生指标
清华有三个坑位
齐哥检索他一志愿前面有两个人在里面
清华尚有一个空缺
所以齐哥会投档到清华
清华再来看专业
一定期有人你不能去
专业二土木
有人你也不能去
但是他服从调剂
所以齐高会被调剂去到清华数学
齐哥就会去清华学数学时来运转
检索第四名框框
一志愿三个坑位都满员
你不能投进去了
检索你的二志愿
华科计算机上有一个名额
不是不是不是
就华科整体还有两个名额
你都能填进去
然后你的这个这个志愿表呢
你是华科计算机是一志愿吗
所以你会被安排到华科的计算机
所以最后的安排是一哥清华电器夫人
清华土木齐哥
清华数学框框
华科计算机我们都去985了
听懂没有啊
所以说框框还还还还吊的人
这个你没理解清楚啊
不敢想象
齐哥居然去学了数学
那不行吗
哎学过石油的语文老师
不是不能学成一个学过数数学的语文老师吗
对不对
齐哥就变成学过数学的语文老师了啊哈懂了吧
这就是平行志愿啊
好接下来那什么叫顺序志愿呢
很简单
平行志愿是分数优先吗
顺序志愿是志愿优先
也就是说你如果是全省第一名
你即使把清华放在二志愿
你也不如全省的第1万名
别人把清华放在一志愿
这就叫顺序志愿
但顺序志愿你不用了解那么多
因为顺序志愿在所有省份
都不是平行批次的录取
一般只在提前批用顺序注录取
所以家长同学记住啊
去看看你们省的招生招生的这个规则
如果你们提前批是顺序志愿录取的话
你就记住啊
你的第一志愿最重要就这么简单
没了啊
好刚才讲的是最原本的平行志愿的录取规则
但是它不是具体到每个省份的情况来
家长同学来了啊
请新疆西藏同学出列扣一
新疆西藏的同学
你们的报考情况和刚才讲的就是一模一样
刚才我讲的就是老高考
你们当地的院校模式好不好好
请刚才院校专业组有调剂省份同学出列
扣二要开始讲专业组了啊
扣二扣二
刚才不是让你们记省份吗
Q 2q2
好同学学长
其实你们的情况就是刚才的情况的复杂延伸版
刚才不是一个学校
是一个志愿吗
到你们这是一个学校的专业组
是一个志愿
你们有调剂
你们调剂是在专业组内调剂
而不是在专业组间调剂
听懂了吗
其实模式是一模一样的
只不过院校变成了专业组而已
那么接下来帮你看一看啊
你们填的时候来
这是我帮你们拉的样表
很简单
看到没有没有填的啊
就是一个专业组
然后在专业组内点是不是服从调剂
这个很直观啦
能不能看懂啊
这应该能看懂好
那么接下来我们就再来练一练啊
嘿嘿
额还是一样的题干哦
稍微复杂一点
这个因为专业组复杂一点啊
好这题干我念一下
如果说一个省
它采用的是院校加专业组的这个录取模式
全省有且仅有六个考生
考生变多了
以前是四个
现在变六个了
一哥考了680分
夫人考了672分
来了个新同学杰哥啊
杰哥考了671分
小猪考了670
但是小猪呢虽然和杰哥都是671分
但小猪他的位次他低于杰哥
因为同分不同位啊
每个同学都有自己固定的这个位次
你同分也是不同位的啊
所以小猪的位次低于几个啊
然后齐哥是670分
框框是668分
好这个时候来了几个专业
来来几个院校来招生啊
有且还是只有清华和华科来招生
但是他们有不同分组
清华零一组包括一个电器和一个土木
清华零二组包括一个化工
华科零一组包括一个计算机和一个机械
华科零二组包括一个数学
然后我们每个人的志愿都是一模一样的
志愿一清华零一组专业医师
电气专业是土木
我们服从调剂志愿
二是清华的零二组
化工是专业一
然后服从调剂志愿
三是华科林一组填计算机
只有一个
没有没有第二个专业了啊
我们服从调剂
然后四志愿是华科林二组专业一数学
我们不服从调剂好
请问因为题干比较复杂啊
题干比较复杂
给大家一分钟时间
请问每个人的志愿到底如何安排
一分钟
这个这个提案比较复杂
题干比较复杂啊
一分钟啊
一分钟安排一下啊
安排一下
大家安排一下每个人的位次啊
安排下每个人的专业啊
最后怎么投档了啊
空花滑档啦
空空滑档了吗
空旷又滑档啦
其实滑档
但你们做的不太对啊
不太一样
你们可以先说吧
呵呵好
半分钟过去了
半分钟过去了啊
扣完滑档了吗
杰克滑档了
杰哥会滑档啊
杰哥为什么会滑档
嘿嘿呵呵呵
还有20秒啊
还剩20秒啊
看你们能不能理解录取规则啊
能不能理解好
最后十秒倒计时十987654321
好
开讲很简单
刚才的原则和上面是一模一样的
只不过你复杂成了专业组而已
来吧分数优先
对不对
先检索一哥一哥检索一志愿清华零一组
电气是专业一
没有人去
你去啦
夫人检索一志愿一志愿两个名额
只有一个坑位
现在还有坑位空缺
那么你进去进进了清华领一组没问题
投进去啦
电器有一个赞
你就读了
土木没问题
夫人去了清华的土木
然后到杰哥
清华零一组就两个指标
两个指标都占满了人
所以一志愿不成立
我检索你的二志愿
二志愿没人
他投进去了
而且读了一卷就是化工
这个很正确啊
我们来看第四名小猪
小猪诶
看一志愿满员
两个人都有了
二志愿也满员
一个人也都有了
检索你的三志愿
三志愿反正没人
你先投进去诶
小朱投进去后
你的专业医师计算机
OK反正没人先安排你
小猪去华科读的计算机
OK好像看齐哥齐哥就有点不一样
很多人同学很多同学可能就在这这来
一志愿满员
二志愿满员
但注意啊
三志愿有两个招生指标哦
一个机械
一个计算机
现在只有一个人
所以奇哥会被华科零一组投过去
让华科里给他安排专业专业
一计算机有人了
小猪在里面
专业二你没填嗯
有点有点懊恼
但是一看哦
你服从调剂
你就调剂去了华科的机械
所以齐哥去华科读了机械
而看框框零一啊
一志愿满员
二志愿满员
三志愿两个人也满员
四志愿没有人
框框被华科零二组提档
框框里面没有人
零二组里面没有人
框框被华科数学录取了
听懂了吗
正是因为齐哥
他服从调剂
他被安排去了华科的机械
所以每个人都有安排
懂了吗啊
这是二啊
这二好
请扣三的同学哪里说的机械表格
并同学在干什么
我题干里面说了啊
华科零一组有一个机械的招生指标
下面这个表格又不是招
又不又不
这个是志愿表
这不是招生指标
这志愿表嗯好啦
老师如果齐哥不服从调剂呢
不服从调剂
他就滑了
听懂没有啊
好了来来来好
刚才讲的是专业组的模式
那接下来各位站的各位同学
请刚才扣三同学出列
co3同学出列
你们是新高考没有调剂
专业加院校的模式哪几个
辽宁河北
山东浙江重庆
贵州青海
你们的志愿极其简单
因为你们没有调剂
你们每一个志愿就是你们填上去的专业很简单
你看这是你们的样表
每一个志愿就是一个院校加一个专业
你不会被你没有填到的专业录取
一定是你填到专业才录取你
所以我们来练一练还这个题干
比如说如果你是专业加院校模式来录取的话
六个考生还是刚才那个位置
然后清华华科来招生
清华有一个电器
一个土木
一个化工
华科有一个机械
一个一个计算机和机械
一个数学
我们的志愿表还是一模一样的
很简单
分数优先
先看一哥
一哥一志愿安梅然
清华电竞
你去夫人看你一志愿有人了
看二志愿清华土木没人
你去三第三个杰哥
你第三名一二志愿有人了
你去小猪
第四名解锁123都有人了
四卷华科计算机你去
然后看齐哥1234卷有人了
五志愿华科机械
你去框框12345都有人啊
六志愿华科数学
你去
很简单
所以没有调剂成分
非常幸福
你们被录取的就是你自己填上去的专业
没有调剂
风险极其简单
没调剂太爽了
担架同学这个模式不可能全国推广的
因为如果全国都推广的话
那么冷门专业就没有人读了
所以你们很简单啊
超简单极其简单好了
那么关于专业录取规则
你们是都懂了
那接下来这同学就讲一个更真诚的一个话题了
提前批到底要不要报
提前批一般包括哪些呢
比如说强基计划
比如综合评价
比如说军事公安这种军事院校
比如说定向公费师范生
比如说定向医学航海招飞港校啊
部分的港校
部分院校的招生呃
港校其实相对比较少了
这个有点误解
这样吧
部分学校的照顾专业
他们会在普通批次之前录取
那这样同学
因为提前批一般遵循的是顺序志愿录取
所以一定要看你们本省录取规则
是不是顺序志愿
一旦是顺序志愿录取的话
那就代表你的一志愿极其的重要
而且各位站各位同学
每一年都有同学这么去考虑
哎呦提前批不填白不填
反正是我给了一个优待
这样同学我请问你们这么想的吗
不能不能
我给大家提个醒啊
如果一旦你被提前批的院校录取了
就代表你的档案被提走了
你后面所有的普通批次全部作废
能听懂吗
你不要觉得哎呦
提前批录了以后
我普通批接着录
我自己决定到底去提前批还是去普通批
所以你不要觉得TMP全是捡漏的啊
每一年都有啊
真的以为提前批就是纯简陋的方向
结果发现我真的被录了
结果不想去
这个很重要啊
好不好
然后引申一下
请问提前批要服从调剂吗
因为提前批如果你掉档了
你的普通批还能接着录取
所以我个人认为提前批你可以不服从调剂
再接下来家长同学
26年提前批有什么新的变化
第一示范缩写好
我们刚才其实讲的一个话题
你应该能感受到很多地方的定向师范名额锐减
甚至有地方定向师范已经不招生了
OK然后专项家长同学
你要关注一下专上专项计划
家长同学如果你应该知道呃
你们知道自己能不能填专项吗
有的有知道的
扣一啊
专项计划今年在部分省份有变化
以前都在提前批
现在有不少的省份放在普通PC里面去录取了
所以你就以前是TMP的录取规则啊
现在你要放普通P咯
要放点普通P那个样本
你们去考虑了这个你们要自己关注关注啊
好不好好
接下来讲一个概念叫分数清和专业清
这东西你们可能在部分的比如说什么啊
视频啊或者直播里面碰到
我想给你们提个醒啊
分数清和专业轻
它很类似于平行志愿和顺序志愿
只不过是当你投档去了
确定一个专
这个确定了一个院校以后
他给你安排专业的方式
这个东西在无调剂省份是没有的
只有在有调剂省份才有
但是请大家记住
在绝大部分的院校
基本上安排专业都是采用分数轻的原则
先看分数再看你的志愿
而如果是专业青
他先看你的志愿倾向
专业倾向
再来看你的分数
你可能不能理解
我来给你练个例子
你就懂了
好来列个例子啊
奇哥框框都被投到这一个院校里面去了
但院校要给他安排他的专业情况
如果这个学校采用分数清来对专业做个分配
假如说入党的四个学生
一个第一名夫人
第二名
七个第三名筐
第四名啊
这个学校呢一共有四个专业
分别是计算机
一个人
电气一个人
数学一个人
土木一个人
而我们分别的志愿按这么来填的
一哥是计算机电气数学
土木夫人是计算机
数学电气土木齐哥数学计算机电气土木框框
电气数学
计算机土木
我们最后分别会安排到什么专业
30秒
你们看一看好吧
很简单啊
这个类似于平行志愿的规则
分数优先遵循志愿
我们分别怎么安排啊
30秒
大家看看怎么安排专业啊
怎么安排专业
很简单啊
这个很简单
如果刚才拼音注音
你理解这个就很简单
超简单啊啊好倒计时五秒钟啊
54321好
开始了啊
好平行志愿的规则嘛
分数优先嘛对先看一哥
一哥要选计算机
一哥去了计算机
再看夫人
夫人是第二名
对不对
看夫人计算机有人了不行
数学OK夫人学了数学
数学还没人
再看第三名
齐哥数学有人啦
夫人去啦
计算机有人啦
一哥去啦
你去电气电气没人看框框框框电器啊不行
齐哥去啦
数学不行
富人去了
计算机不行
一哥去啊
你只能去土木
所以一哥计算机夫人数学齐哥电器框框土木好
变量来了
还是一样的题干
如果这个学校他的安排专业的方式
采用的是专业清的话
那么我们分别会把安排到什么专业
还有30秒
顺序志愿啊
和顺序志愿差不多
听懂没有
第一志愿最重要介绍专业清了以后
我们分别四个人什么专业
学过电气的语文老师
齐哥和这个梗过不去了
又学数学
又学石油
学电气啊
太搞笑了
嗯还是一样的
怎么可能是一样的
同学你就没好好听讲
这个类似于顺序志愿
第一志愿最重要
就MULAN这个观点就知道第一志愿最重要
好了五秒倒计时开始啊
543210家长它类似于顺序志愿
也就是说先看志愿
所以一哥计算机是一志愿
夫人计算机也是一志愿
但齐哥一志愿是数学框框
一卷是电器
而一哥的位次高于夫人
也就是说一哥去了计算机
齐哥去了数学框框
去了电器
因为他们都是第一志愿
而夫人再去看他
哎呦
计算机有人啦
数学在看数学也有一志愿的人在里面啦
电器有电器
有一志愿的人在里面
所以夫人去了土木
最后我们的安排是一哥计算机夫人土木
齐哥数学框框电器安排的专业就完全不一样了
家长同学今年专业青
也有部分学校有他相关的这个这个安排
安排分数
但是安排专业
但是相关的学校并不多
所以请大家在选择院校的时候
一定要去看
那招生章程里面会明确写
我在采用分数清还是专业清
好不好
OK这过了
然后专业级差这些东西就不听啦
这个东西现在基本上
反正目前为止我没看到有有有学校
它是采用专业级差
这东西很恶心啊
你们也不用听了啊
如果真的碰到的话
之后再说啊
好不好
专业性你不用了解了
以前是有的
现在几乎没有了
这就过了好
当我们把所有的前情要点全部解释完了以后
接下来我们就要一步一步一步
带你把志愿表填出来了
加同学六步法
第一确定位词
好同学
我们情景代入一下啊
今天是6月25号
突然你收到一个短信
省教育考试院给你发来一条信息
同学你好
在2026年普通高等学校招生考试当中
你今年的分数是多少分
你的全省位次是多少名
现在有了分数有了
为此我们就要开始真正哎吓哭什么啊
在干干什么就开始讲课了
吓哭什么好
这个时候呢我们要分什么讨论
有的省份啊他会明确在短信当中既把分数
又把位次告诉你
这里很好
你啥都有了
但是有的省份他只告诉你分数
这个时候你要去查这个东西
叫一分一段表
这同学把一分一段表扣在评论区啊
一分一段表它是指这个分数
他会给你个区间
全省有多少人分数
比如说啊1万到1万2啊
都是考了600分
600对应1万的1万2
所以这里面当中位次都是对应600分
叫一分一段表
这个时候同学这样
我请问你在填志愿的时候
你要参考哪个位置
如果省份不告诉你确定的位置啊
你只有个模糊的区间
我告诉你一定要用更大的那个位词来填志愿
因为填志愿他的原则叫做求稳
听懂没有
比如说刚才讲的666百名对应1万到1万2
那你就用1万2来给填志愿
用更大的那个位次啊
用更低的那个位次
记住了吗
第一个叫确定位次
因为填志愿不看分数
看的是位次
今年高考很难对吧
建高考数学尤其难贼难
那你的位次哦
虽然可能你今年的分数比去年低了一点点
但你的位次不会大变呐
对不对啊
第一个第一步就确定位置
这个很简单啊
接下来确定标杆院校
同学家长把三扣在评论区
把三这个数字扣在评论区
请记住
如果你去做往年录取参考的话
一定要用3年
一年不算数
两年也有风险
看3年好不好
O怎么确定你的标杆院校呢
这样同学因为试卷难度不同
所以分数没有可比性
因为考生人数和招生指标不同
所以一定要去换算
估计在现在一共有三种主流方法
第一种叫做同位分
也叫位次法
这个采用的是最多的
很多的这种志愿填报软件也采用的是谓词法
很简单
同学就是比如说你今年考了多少分
你去查今年的一分一段表
你有了这个位次以后
哎
看看在去年前年大前年这个位置下
往年一分一表表一段表对应什么分数
那么这个分数在往年录到什么学校
什么专业
那这个就是你的标杆院校
我举个例子吧
比如说你考620分
对不对
620分对应了全省的2000名
那你看往年的在去年前年大前年
去年前年大前年
比如去年我就举一个你个年份
去年全省的2000名
对应的是630分
你就去看去年630分录到是什么学校
什么专业
那就是你的标杆院校
丹尼尔同学
我不知道你有没有刷到一个新闻
说今年双一流院校会持续扩招
听过没有
很多优质生源院校要持续扩招
优本扩容
听过没有
应该听过啊
不知道你们刷到这新闻没有
那么这样的
同学们
我请问在持续扩招的背景之下
你采用同位分或者位次法去做一个估计的话
你的志愿填的会不会趋于保守
能理解这个逻辑吗
去年你能上华中科技大学
同样的分数和同样同样的位次
你上华中科技大学
今年你可能能上更好的院校了
因为他扩招了
能理解吧
对不对
但是填保守没有错
因为志愿填报保守了也无所谓
志愿填报本身是让你有书读
OK稍微亏点
彼此好
这第一种啊叫做谓词法
第二个叫做线插法
也是用批字线来做个参考
什么叫批次线呢
在我们现在的这个收分过程当中
有有专科线
有本科线
有哦
新高考的特供线
如果是新疆西藏老高考的话
有一本线
有二本线
对不对
二本线是本科线
这就叫批次线
同学如果你的位次性分数位于批次线的附近
每个批次线都可以啊
只能班专科线
本科线
一本线
二本线
特控线
只要这个分数线附近都可以啊
附近大概20分都OK
那么你采用线差法是最科学的方法
我举个例子吧
比如说你今年考了500分
比如今年你们本省的本科线是480分
你不是高了20分吗
你看往年的录取线
如果去年本科线是470分
你就对应是去年470加二十四百九十分
能懂吗
能不能听懂
所以啊如果你的位置呢位于批次线的附近
用线插法是能帮你更好确定标杆院校的
更科学的方法
那接下来同学有一个更不一样的计算方式
叫做位次转换法
嘿嘿哈哈嗯
等一下啊
好来看这个啊
为此转化是说因为每一年招生人数都会有变化
考生数也会有变化
批次线的地方也会有变化
所以我们会对它进行一个位次
或招生计划的一个放缩
他有一个方法
他有一个这个这个这个比例啊
怎么去放松呢
计算公式是今年的位次来除以今年的批次
线的位次
等于往年的位次除以往年的批次线的位次
相当于把今年的扩招啊
今年整体的分数或者线的变化呀
集中考虑进来了
去对应一下往年情况
比如举个例子吧
520分
你对应全省的1万名
而离你最近的PC线
比如说特控线它是500分
对应全省的1万2000名
而往年这个批次线
比如特控线是15000千米
你就可以求出X了
1万÷12000
等于X除以1万5000
你就可以把X求出来了
当求出来以后
你就求出了往年的对应的位置
你查往年的一份零顿表
看往年分数
往年的这个学校就是你的标杆院校
标记重捕法对
是的是的
标记重法
你们学生物的应该知道标记重捕法啊
但是啊同学这样
我要给你打个预防针
因为现在在持续扩招
很多人求出这个X你可能不敢用
你会觉得哇我能去到这么好的学校吗
同学这样可以的
但如果你真的非常害怕
那你就用传统的保守的谓词法就可以了
他至少保守不会出错
听懂了吗
所以三种方法如果你用位次法一定不会出错
只不过越靠后
你会填的越保守
你位置越靠后
填的会填的越保守
第二个方法
会采用的更科学的办法
第三个很多人都用的谓词转换法
但是他做出来的结果会相对比较激进
你如果害怕的话就算了啊
好不好啊
呵呵呵啊
这样有点听不懂
没关系没关系
我们这个会呃放成回放
明天到时候你可以再来看看好吧
因为这个东西他肯定要反复咀嚼啊
用公式一套一套出来了啊
好不好啊
好这个是第二个这样的同学
当你把标杆院校求出来了以后
接下来叫冲文宝啦
对不对
把冲文宝扣在评论区啊
冲文宝别人是不是都和你说
哎呦
填志愿我们要冲稳保啊
冲一冲
稳一稳
保一保
弄完以后
你才能把整个志愿表给他弄出来啊
冲文宝基本的院校够一够
够不到够一够冲一冲
然后稳一稳
然后再保一保啊
家长经验法则告诉你
基本上要1/3拿来冲
1/3拿来稳
1/3拿来保
但是真的如此吗
其实不见得
我们要分有调剂成份和无条件省份
来来来
老高考和新高考院校专业组模式
如果有条件扣个一或者扣个二
有条件什么的
先出列再说
无条件
都知道刚才说了啊
扣一块二
哪些省份啊
这样的同学请问因为你们有调剂
那你是不是如果要冲
你只敢冲干净的专业组
不干净的专业组
如果你冲的话
调剂的是不是基本都是你
你去读冷门专业对吗
但是干净的专业组你能冲得上去吗
你当你前面人全是瞎子
你去冲一个呃
比你位次高高1000名的这种干净专业组
你当前面1000人都是个瞎子
对不对
所以一般人冲都冲不上去
所以说啊有调剂成分
我个人建议
如果你对专业有要求
我个人建议全部拿来稳和保不冲也是一种智慧
哎呦我怎么讲的这么有哲理的话
哈哈V扣在评论区啊
不冲也是一种智慧
此时吻和保怎么去做
我个人建议60%哪来稳
40%哪来保啊
懂不懂
哎呀打什么问号啊
你在干什么啊
同学们
我们讲课啊
正经点啊
打什么问号啊
不冲也是一种智慧
呵好
我们直播间有没有这种人啊
就比如说哎专业本身什么无所谓
只要让我上到一个更好的院校就可以了
院校平台就行啊
读什么土木啊
水利啊
环境啊
OKOK我不care我不靠专业吃饭
有的扣一有没有有没有啊
有没有啊
同学如果你是这样的人的话
那无所谓了
你随便便冲不干净的专业组
你也给我冲条件的也无所谓
对不对啊
好冲就讲完了
稳要重点讲了
因为稳是我们最后一定会被录取的区间
是你最有可能录取部分最稳的部分
你必须要好好研究
而且要放入最多比例加同学
如果你是有调剂啊
假如干净专业组
你肯定要报
放进去
没有任何问题
报不报得上再说
对不对
如果面临不干净的专业组
我们怎么考虑
你不要完全放弃
如果你完全放弃了
你会发现你填的志愿没有那么多
很多干专业组都不干净的啊
我们分类讨论一下
如果这个专业组里面
你能接受的专业只有一到两个
你能够得上
而且这一到两个这个专业的话
他的位次一直是比较平稳
而且持续往下走的
你预留五分可以报
但是如果这一到两个专业
你报他是干什么
说不定今年就冲不
你就稳不到了
你就稳不到
你就上不了了
那其他你就被调剂了
对不对
那这时候你就不报了啊
如果一个专业组里面有一半的专业以上
你都能接受
是在你的稳的区间的话
那么这个专业组你就可以报了
没有问题啊
好那么到宝这个区间都到宝了
对不对
你到兜底了
同学怎么去做你的保的区间呢
很简单
就这五个字啊
就这十个字叫小保底
做密大保底守住什么意思
你保底的志愿里面不是有很多志愿吗
越靠上的志愿你给做密一点
可能分数差个一两分
位次差的密一点就是紧一点
但越往下你的位次拉的越开
越到保底
你的位置拉得越开
你把越往下沉的地方拉的越开
把大保底守住就可以了
比如说你的你的保的区间里面可能有十个志愿
对不对
第一个保的志愿和第二个保志愿差个一分
第三个保的卷和第二保志愿差个一分
第四个宝卷和第三个保志愿差两分
第十个宝卷和第九个保志愿差五分
差十分
懂了吗
这叫小保底作弊
大保底守住
什么叫小保底
会不会歪啊
歪了呀
你知道什么
什么叫小保底歪了
不是我有点代沟啦
这是什么意思啊
什么叫小保底
歪了进去哦
抽卡哦
哦哦哦哦哦哦哦哦哦这样的啊
哦我知道我知道啊
那那那不不是哦
原来这样的
那我知道了
我也平时也玩游戏啊
哦你们突然跳到游戏了
我真的服了
我这我都没反应过来
我说你在干在说什么好吧
这有调剂啊
有调剂啊
来来来
无调剂省份同学出列扣三呐
出列无条件审犯
怎么充文榜啊
就这样很简单
因为你们没有调剂嘛
你根本不会被你不想填的志愿给他录取
所以你可以从录不录得上无所谓嘛
对不对
你可以多充
没有问题
你反正没调剂无所谓啊
但你的称文宝一定要拉开梯度
确保你保的志愿
最后一定能把你最后的下限给他兜住
懂吗
因为你们太爽了
你们没有调剂啊
我说极端一点
这样的同学
比如你们96个志愿
极端一点啊
90个拿来充
五个拿来稳
最后一个把底线兜住
你一定不会滑档
爽不爽
但是我不介意
我建议您怎么投放你们指标呢
这么来啊
同学家长啊
嘿嘿嘿
如果你愿意赌的是赌狗的扣一
如果你比较稳健的扣二
如果是赌狗
我建议啊3%额哎
这个这个反了
我个人建议
因为稳稳要多一点
不好意思啊
这个这个反了
改一下啊
如果是赌狗
30%拿来充
40%拿来稳
30%拿来保
如果你扣二比较稳健
其实我更建议你稳健一点
因为填志愿你不是拿来豪赌的
填志愿不是一篇豪读
填志愿是让你有有书读懂吗
所以我建议啊15%拿来充
55%拿来稳
30%拿来保
但是都可以啊
反正你把底线堵住就可以了
把底线底线兜住就可以了
好这个时候家长同学
刚才讲的是冲文宝是你的专业的设置的问题
那么我们如果来到有调剂省份
你们是不是有专业组内的专业排序呀
同一天生对吗
我来预测一下你们怎么去挑志愿的
哎哟去年专业组这个第一个专业嗯
收分最一次最高
我把它放第一个专业
第二个专业这个位次第二名我放第二专业
第三个位次
第三名我放第三个专业
是不是这样来的
你是不是这样来的
你是不是不要这么难啊
我的天哪
你在干什么
专业组内你最好也给我排个序
给我拉开梯度
怎么排序啊
我们直播间会给你介绍这四个方向
第一个看这个专业的市场薪资到底如何
薪资待遇可以通过各大招聘软件里面去观察
观察平均数
观察中位数都可以啊
但平均数因为很多很多软件以前我会讲
你要注重中位数
但是有点不现实
因为很多软件它只公布平均数
所以有平均数
你可以参考平均数
如果两个都有的话
观察他的中位数比平均数更加的优先啊
因为我和马云平均一下
我也是亿万富翁
好不好
所以啊如果有展示中位数
看中位数啊
如果没有的话
看平均数就可以了
好再往下看薪资
看薪资
大家把薪资扣在平均薪资
薪资啊
薪资好
第二个你要去了解一下市场的需求
在专业当中我们会把市场需求
你以后就业的方向的话
就业的需求分成两个方向
一个叫体制内
一个叫体制外
体制内很简单
家长同学听过公务员吗
听过央国企吗
听过事业编吗
一般来说就是体制内啊
在公务员考试当中
国考省考当中
他确实有对于专业的排序
而送佛送到西
我这个人就喜欢做善事
嘉爱同学
我帮你们统计了2026年的国考当中
从第一名到第十名的专业大类
越靠前的考公岗位数相对更多
如果你奔着考公去
可以优先考虑考虑以上这相关的专业啊
就这等明天这个直播回放出来以后
值不值得点个赞
收个藏
投个币
转个发
评个论呐
这样的同学啊
这么好的这个主播啊
你在哪去找
对不对啊
好刚才讲的是体制内啊
体制内我们公考当中排序好
什么叫事业编呢
事业编很多同学这样不理解
我给大家
我给大家讲四个字
也就理解了
科教文卫扣在评论区吧
科教文卫科学事业
教育事业
文化事业
卫生事业全是事业编
基本都是他们泛指体制内
而体制内讲得非常明确
我这个岗位要什么需求的专业写得清清楚楚
明明白白
所以体制内的岗位专业需求非常好统计
那如果体制外呢
比如说你要去民企
你要去私企
要去外企
同学啊
去相关的招聘软件或招聘平台里面
去找他们的需求
而我在2022年3月份
已经给你们做了一个总结性的视频
这个视频现在已经108万播放了啊
每一年都在涨啊
都是一届学生搜上去的啊
帮你做了完整的总结
所有企业看这个相关的总结就可以了
去哪个渠道找好不好啊
怎么样啊
这个这个这个主播老师值得关注啊
等大学以后你还你还会需要的啊
呵呵好
体制位的这个相关的市场需求
这么来看
这是第二个
第三个
这样同学你可以看一下专业的学习内容
这点很重要
为什么我们很多家长不理解
很多家长会天然觉得哎呦
孩子读完大学
读了大学以后
他天然就能毕业
毕业就能找工作
但同学
我请问你在本科当中的学习幸福度重不重要
你如果这个专业啃不下来
学习的非常辛苦
非常痛苦
那你为什么学他呢
你学的不好
你找什么工作呢
很重要
但很多家长会天然忽视掉这一点
所以我直播间我会强调
你必须要看这个专业的学习内容怎么看
比如说看培养方案
去很多学校里面去看啊
他的教务处啊
教育学院官网里面都会有每个专业的培养方案
他能去给你说这个本科专业他要学什么课程
但是这个课程它是一些专有名词
看起来很枯燥
你看不懂对不对
所以你要去看网课资源去
比如说中国大学慕课
阿B某音等等
很多平台都有啊
去把这公公开课给他搜出来
你大概几倍速啊
两倍速
三倍速
四倍速
五倍速
30倍速
你看看过不过哎我能啃得下来
那么你再选择
懂了吗
所以学习内容也很重要啊
好不好啊
好再往下
你如果在做排序的话
你要去看一下专业的学科实力
这个东西我们就我们就不说了
因为刚才讲过怎么去看
比如学科评估呃
双一流怎么去看
我们在第二部分都讲过
你到时候去看第二部分
帮你做学科排序就可以了
好这个时候你专业组里面就可以把
按此来做个专业的排序
而且这样的同学我请问我们思考问题
冲文宝是仅仅指专业组的充文宝吗
其实我认为不见得
对于有调剂省份
充文宝更应该指的是专业组内的充文宝
什么意思
因为有调剂啊
你最好填的专业拉开梯度
你自己做一个主动调剂
你一定不会被你没有选到的专业给他录取
能听懂吗
我举个例子吧
比如说一个专业组20个专业
其中四个专业你完全能接受
电子信息
电气机器人自动化好
有六个专业你相对能接受机械材料等等等等
但有十个专业你完全不接受这样的同学
我请问这个时候你怎么安排
专业组内的专业排序啊
我希望你能够在你最后那两个专业
把机械材料给他垫上
因为他们收分相对比较低
你主动选择你自己又能接受
能听懂吗
你自己主动做个调剂
没有听人讲过这个吧
就这句话就值得你关注了哈哈懂了没有
你主动调剂啊
你主动做个调剂好了
这个是讲的专业组内的排序啊
然后接下来我们要一个一个做志愿排序哦
家人们其实我告诉你啊
我做一个
我做一个上帝视角
我我我告诉你一个预言家的视角
同意这样你们最后在会在什么情况犯难
你们最后会会在
我把哪个志愿放在更靠前的位置
哪个志愿把它放在靠后的位置
哪个放前
哪个放后
你会在这边犹豫很久
因为我们是遵循志愿来做录取的
对不对
所以你最后一定要做一个志愿的排序
那这同学怎么排序啊
我们在第四部分不是讲过了吗
学校专业和地区怎么排序
按我刚才那个原则
你一个一个做下来
就能把它排序排出来了
最后排序你得遵循两个原则
同学家同学家长记住啊
第一个
请你务必确保
每一个志愿都比后面所有的志愿更加的优秀
什么意思
一志愿要优于23456789十志愿
二志愿要优于3456789十志愿
十志愿要优于十一十二十三志愿
20志愿
由于21223志愿每个志愿要比更耗后的
就每个志愿都比他后面的所有志愿更加的优先
但这个东西没有人能告诉你标准答案
因为每个人评价学校院校的标准都不一样
只能你自己排
OK听懂吗
第二个请你务必把这个表填出来了以后
面对每一个选项问自己一个问题
如果我真的被这个学校这个专业录取了
我能不能接受
同意接上
每一年都有学生最后录取
发现他录取的学校和专业
他自己压根都不知道
真的有
为什么
我举个例子吧
第一调剂了
第二田志愿赌气了
我之前有个学弟啧
被录到了西南大学的地质学啊
西南交通大学地质学
他压根没有填
这个是为什么呢
填志愿的过程当中
和爸妈吵架
离家出走了
最后那几那几十个专业是他爸妈给他填的
这个录取真的被后面这个志愿给他录取了
所以这样同学这事每年都有发生哦
所以啊请你们务必面对你填的每个志愿问清楚
如果我真的被这个志愿录取了
我能不能接受好不好
志愿排序要这么来弄啊
OK啊好
最后第六步把检查扣在评论区
检查检查检查家
我们检查扣在评论区啊
很重要啊
检查这最后一步必须要做
必须要做
必须要做检查
检查什么
最重要
就是检查招生章程
比如说这个学校录取规则如何
专业清吗
分数轻吗
以前有专业级差
我把它划下来
现在没有专业级差了
看清楚他的专业分配模式
然后学费什么
是不是高收费
是不是中外合作
这很重要
很多家庭没有办法能够一年拿出这么多学费的
就不要填高收费项目了
第三个有没有单科成绩限制要求
如果学校在招生程里面明确写到我
比如英语要多少分
你真的不达标
第四个身体条件有没有什么这个这个这个色盲
色弱
如果有限制的话
所以最后要检查这些全部要检查清楚啊
那么家长们
同学们在讲检查的时候
滑档这点事情在做检查时候一定要去关注的啊
这样同学
就是当你的档案已经被投到某个学校了
结果如果你有调剂成分
你没勾服从调剂啊
对不对
然后你你的专业都有人占满了
然后如果你是有条件无条件什么都可以啊
你没满足刚才讲的单科成绩和身体条件
你不满足学校要求
或者是下一批次录取啊
那什么叫滑档呢
很简单
同学就叫做所有志愿都报高了
比如说你96个志愿
每个志愿都报高了
你就滑档了
这个批次无一个学校可以投档
但是呢他最后结果差不多就是你反正真题卷
要么下个批次录取啊
所以这很恐怖啊
这个我要讲清楚
首先有调剂成份
记住所有的选项务必全部要勾
选服从调剂
无一幸免
全部要勾
如果你不勾的话
必须勾服从调剂
必须勾必须勾必须勾啊
第二个
无论你是有调剂省份还是无调剂省份
必须要看招生章程
去检查单科成绩要求和身体条件要求
记住了吗
好不好
只要你做好这两个
那么如何避免滑档呢
这样的同学刚才不是说了吗
滑档叫做你所有志愿全部报高了
那我把兜底志愿最后一个志愿给填好
不就得了吗
我不填高不就得了吗
对不对
所以说怎么避免滑档
你要把兜底志愿做好
把兜底两个字扣在评论区
那兜底卷啊
我这边设几个标准啊
首先你建我建议兜底怎么去兜呢
第一首先下探30分
主动下探30分
30分
如果你还没都上底的话
那呵肯定都上顶了
30分已经很多了很多了
你如果再保守
你多个40分也可以啊
但是30分够了
四五十四五十分也可以啊
都30分啊
30分最后的志愿都到30分
然后一定要是本省高校
为什么家长
因为你们本省高校
在你们本省招生的指标是比较多的
外省很多在你们本省就招那么一两个
他是有风险的
所以啊一定要用本省的院校来做兜底志愿
第三个要选择招生计划比较多的专业
为什么
因为刚才说了
如果招生计划就那么一两个
你也不知道你前面有有谁
就为自高一的
他突然这个这这这一时脑热
我就把这个填了
那你来兜底
别人兜上了
你兜什么底啊
对不对
你兜不了底了
所以我建议啊招生计划数要多于十个的
你在做兜底志愿
最后你一定要选个好专业
家长你都兜底了
你院校都妥协了
你还不选个好专业吗
那你不是啥啥都不占嘛
对不对
不介意啊
好不好
所以建议呢这四个下单30分
本省高校招生计划比较多的以及好专业
那哪些不建议你把它当做兜底志愿的
第一个院校
改名的这个很简单
院校改名
我天呐
我我举个例子
比如说去年有个学校叫做框框学院
然后今年他改名了叫框框大学
家长同学
我请问你他今年会不会涨分啊
啊你更意读学院还是更愿意读大学啊
那肯定大学嘛
那今年一定有涨分的预期
你报它干什么都不聊底了
今年会涨分
兜啥底啊
对不对
都不聊了
第二个去年断档的学校
你就不能兜底了
什么意思
就是去年我举个例子吧
呃比如说有个学校
他往年都是1万位
今年额收分
最后就是录取到最后一个文人的时候
突然没人报了
后面人都不敢报
1万1的人没人报
1万2的人没人报
诶
突然有个2万位的人捡漏了
他填了这个学校
正好有个空缺
他就进去了
那么去年这个学校他的位次就断到了2万位次
这样的同学别人平时是1万的人内啊
你大概比如说可能你个呃1万1万5000位的
你把这个2万位
因为我兜了很到底了
我2万位我都可以兜底
都很好
殊不知别人平时是1万位的位次
你兜什么底啊
明年别人就涨上来了
所以去年断档的就不能作为兜底志愿啊
然后还有啊招生计划数比较少的
小于等于三个的
别当兜底志愿原则刚才说了啊
你有风险啊
然后招生计划缩减的
你也不能当德语志愿吗
这个很简单
我举个例子吧
这样同学们
我请问一个学校
一个专业他招十个人
他收分在630分
我请问他第三名的同学是630分吗
这个问题能不能听懂啊
一个学校招十个人
他收到630分
他第三名是630分吗
那肯定不是肯定比这个分高嘛
对不对
所以一旦他招生计划缩减
今年他这个选项一定有涨分的预期
你就不能把它当做兜底志愿了
最后新院校不能当兜底志愿
为什么
因为新院校谁都不知道他什么实力对吧
有很多人说哎呀
新院校对不对
我把他以为他是1000名的院校
你以为是1万名的院校
然后你1000你你那个1万名的
你觉得诶我可以兜底
我5000名说不这边出来哎呦
4000名
所以新院校啊不能去当兜底职员啊
怎么看断不断档
直接看他过去3年吧
比如说他过去前年大前年都是1万位
然后去年突然变成2万位
那不就断档了吗
懂了没有啊
断档天哪要看好几个数据
对呀
我讲了你的对比3年数据呀
哎呦我天呐
家人们
你们以为就看一年数据啊
看3年你就知道断不断档了啊
嗯好加同学
自此
我们就把所有的关于孩子手把手
志愿填报的规则一步一步讲完
充文宝全部讲完了
但是我们没有结束
到最后我们要来讲讲
志愿填报当中可能会有哪些坑
你一定不要踩
踩
中了的话
你这个志愿就可能把你所有的努力
全部付之东流
我们就我们就不休息了啊
接着往下讲啊
好第一个
请你千万不能以片面的认知来决定专业
因为你自己的认知是有局限的
亲戚朋友老师的认知也都是有局限的
他们不了解中国几乎所有的专业方向
你不能按这样的认知来帮你决定专业
要刚才我们讲的第二种方法
一步一步把你专业给他筛选出来
所以第一个不能这么做
第二个请你不要动
不就不能正式专业劝退
因为你就要辨析刚才讲的大学生工作的人员
他们对于这个专业到底是纯粹的客观的分析
还是纯粹的情绪的分析
如果是后者
他的观点对来说就没有参考价值
请务必去辨别一下
给你分析这个相关专业的人
他的背景是什么
他大学生吗
还是说在这个社会当中能站在比较高层的人
能看到现在整个社会的运行规律
如果是后者
那他的分析对你来说才更有参考价值
这第二个第三个请你千万不要忽视学校条件
这样同学地理位置很重要
我要请你们提醒一下
在挑选专业的时候
一定要去看看这个学校
它有几个校区
以及你读的这个专业在哪个校区
有很多学校你看似在在市中心
实际上新校区贼拉偏远
也许像你看似在上海
在北京
结果在上海北京的郊区离市中心极其的偏远
我们读大学四年3年
甚至如果你读硕读博还要在这
你有很长的时间都要在这的
请你务必要把这个好好去看一看好不好
这点很重要啊
然后再往下你会填到野鸡大学
这个尤其在低分段同学可能会碰到这个问题
这东西呢我帮大家做一个整理
全国高等教育学校的名单
这个东西呢
刚刚去发布了一个最新的名单
这个东西额我给大家整理在课件里面
你们到时候可以去看
最新的学校名单好不好
你如果正规填志愿的话
你不会碰到这个问题
但是如果低分段你受到什么人的蛊惑
说我能让你低分简漏上名校
你不要信啊
有可能是野鸡大学啊
好不好好
再往下
你可能会混淆相似的概念
我们来举个例子
比如说家长同学你能辨清楚吗
比如说哈尔滨工业大学
哈尔滨工程大学
哈尔滨理工大学
这三个学校完全不一样哦
一个是985
一个是211
一个是纯市非院校啊
虽然这实力都还不错啊
但是确实差别挺大的啊
你别弄混了
院校你可能不会弄混
但专业你可能真的会弄混
比如说生物科学和动物科学
生科是理学
动科是农学
生物工程和生物医学工程
生物工程是传统工科
不带电
生物医学工程是新工科
带电计算机科学技术和信息与计算科学
前者是工学
是纯计算机哦
信息与计算科学是理学
是数学大类
同学虽然他的培养偏向于数学家计算机
但是他本人是数学啊
学的很难的
你肯不肯得下来哦
别乱停啊
像眼视光医学和眼视光学
一个是能够做医生的
那是临床医学大学
眼视光学是医学技术代做眼光
眼视光技师的完全不一样好不好
这点很重要
然后再往下人云亦云
同学这样填志愿
填专业
填院校是需要满足你自己的需求的
很多人和你说
这个专业不能报
那个学校
不能报不行
小马过河听过吗
有的人觉得水深
有的人觉得水浅
但对于你而言
它可能不深不浅
所以明确自己的需求
不要人云亦云就好了
再往下一定一定一定要去看招生章程
不看招生章程是不对的
录取政策如何
身体条件如何
单科成绩怎么限制
有没有专业的学费的要求
在招生招生里面全部学的明明白白
清清楚楚
要把这个检查检查好不好
然后再往下填报的志愿
他的决策的这个这个这个决策
实在是太过激进了
我个人不推荐
所以刚才我们讲冲文报的时候
我会讲你不要冲太多
填志愿
本人是一个求稳的过程
保住你有书读
那就更重要
懂了没有好
再往下
如果你来自己有条件省份
一定一定要服从调剂
不服从调剂是错误的
服从调剂存在于老高考
新高考的院校专业组的模式
我个人建议必须要服从调剂
滑档的风险啊
这不是滑档
这说错了
不好意思啊
好然后不能瞎填提前批啊
提前批一定是你自己确认我到底真的要去读
再去填提前批好不好
然后最后家长同学这个是我最想和你们谈的
因为今天直播的呃
我来做个调查
咱们直播呃
是家长在听的扣一是同学在听的
扣二家长扣一同学本人扣二
家长是父母的扣一同学本人扣二呃
家长同学
我想和你谈谈啊
因为每年填志愿到最后时候
我碰过很多案例
填志愿最后的阻力在于
家庭不能达成意见的和谐
不能达成意见的一致
但同意家长
首先如果您作为家长
一定要听孩子本人的想法
因为未来去读大学的是孩子本人
他们如果参与决策
他会为自己未来负责
而同学
我相信今天听我直播和看我视频回放的同学
自己都是主动积极的同学
但有很多同学会把所有的志愿当做甩手掌柜
全部扔给家人
这个做法是极其不负责任的
因为那是你自己未来的人生
我希望你能参与自己
现在18岁
马上要进入大学这么关键的时候
你自己做的第一个人生的重大的决策
所以说我希望决策权父母
家长机构
包括人工智能都会给你各种各样的决定
但是最后能把志愿表填出来的一定是学生本人
否则的话
如果你不不参与这个决策
等到你到时候大学里面过得非常痛苦
或者你发现哎哟我为什么当年会选这个专业
我拿的薪资如此的微薄
你会懊恼
就为什么当时填志愿不是我自己做的决定
因为人生的路只能你自己走
所以你自己做决定
你一定能负责到底
所以好不好
同学家长
我希望今天这场直播
我们所有内容你都能接受
然后能够把志愿表给它填好
但这样的同学
我们这样的同学应该都知道啊
在每次直播的最后呢
我们总会有一些小小的彩蛋啊
今年呢我们也如约来到彩蛋的环节
我和你谈谈啊
就是从去年到现在
我做志愿填报已经完整经历了一年的周期
我前年毕业的嘛
然后今年算是我真正做事业的第一年
我完整的志愿填报的整个起伏一年
这个今年这个行业发生非常多巨变
特别是那位老师的离世
各位让各位同学
你们也都知道
但正是因为这件事
让我看见这个行业里面的众生态
我发现这个行业里面有不少的投机分子
他们觉得这个行业入行门槛极低
然后去年可能是干汽修的
干装修的
然后培训集中个一两个月就就就集中来开直播
发短视频
做机构收着很高价的咨询费用和填报费用
最后给学生给家长带来那个志愿表单
就是那种软件填出来的都不让自己导出的
我极其愤怒
所以志愿填报本身
它是决定孩子未来4年甚至更长时间的
一个关键决策
这个背后有学生的未来
有家庭的期待
所以我才会努力地去做视频
做直播
我想把最真实的内容呈现给不仅是学生
还在人面前
有幸的是啊
在昨天晚上
我们直播间在线人数突破1.3万
今天晚上更多1.6万人
所以说我应该是能够影响很多家庭了
真实真诚实在务实的内容才是必杀技
我可以和拍着胸脯给大家说
我自己是真真正正抱着一份教育
育人初心来做这件事情的
为什么
因为我虽然来自重庆
大家都知道重庆不是个小城市
它是一个直直辖市
但是我爸妈他是当地毛纺厂的职工
在上个世纪90年代
因为国企改革
我的爸妈也下岗了
所以说其实我是真正来自一个非常普通的家庭
在进入大学之前
我的生活可以说非常的普通
甚至有点窘迫
我的爸妈能把我供到像复旦这样大学
他们已经很累了
很辛苦了
我非常感激
但是因为我是普通家庭出来的第一届大学生
在大学里面
大学像个迷宫一样
我根本不知道如何去下脚
有很多条路我不知道怎么去走
在大一的时候
我在班里是倒数第七
在硕士我去参与了很多金融业界实习
我发现我真的不喜欢
我非常的迷茫
我走得很苦也很累
我拼尽全力才找到大学出口
所以我后来15年我做辅导员
做了6年辅导员
我带了500名的学生
20年我开始做教育自媒体
到现在我全力全网积累了近700万的粉丝
我希望能够带领更多学生在大学当中
他们能找到自己的方向
找到属于他们自己的那束光
那回到今天或者这一年当中
我做剧情填报本身这件事
而说志愿填报本身
看似是一些很多东西的排列组合
对大家而言
它可能只是一个很冰冷的文字
是院校是专业还没有落到纸面上
但是其实我们如果排除非常遥远的未来
这些院校和专业
它对应了你大学四年到底在哪生活
碰到什么人
会经历什么样的大学人生
所以在这么关键的节点
我希望啊你能留下足够的转向的空间
因为家长同学们
你应该知道听过很多直播
这样的同学知道
我是一个希望你们在本科填志愿的时候
留足足够宽口径的人
你没有必要在刚刚18岁的时候
把自己的人生陷在如此窄的赛道里面
因为人生是旷野
它不是轨道
你应该在更大的土壤当中去肆意的奔跑
去发泄你自己
所以在这个最美好的
你要开始主宰自己人生的时间
让我想起那个瞬间
2011年
我刚自己刚刚完成志愿填报
过了一个月
我接到复旦大学的录取通知书
那个通知书上面有一句话
我当天看了很久
他怎么写的
恭喜你跻身百年复旦的星空
日月光华中有你闪亮的眼睛
你计划秋天已褪去童话色彩
一个真实的现在可以开垦出1万个美丽的未来
同学大学里面有很多的可能性
确实存在着1万种可能性
但这可能性它有可能向上
也可能向下万千条路
如果没有人指引的话
你大学可能会走丢
没有人指引
可能很难理出头绪
我自己是那个曾经临过的小孩
所以当你填志愿迷茫了
当你在大学迷茫了
当你可能觉得自己走丢了
你可以看看框框的直播
来看框框的视频
也许他能帮你在未来度过那段难熬的时光
这是我做自媒体最大的心愿
所以最后这句话送给大家
我去年也说过
作为结尾
我想郑重郑重的送给你
没有正确的目标
也没有最好的道路
比道路和目标更重要的是你自己本身学习生活
工作都是土壤
从中发现和认识你自己才是未来最大的课题
学生时代没有标准答案
人生的意义是由你自己赋予的
好家同学
今天的直播就到这
明天如果快的话啊
他会当做一个录播回放作为视频发出来
所以如果您觉得这个视频对你有帮助的话
能不能拜托您帮这个视频点赞收藏
阿B这边可以投个币啊
转发转发
让他能被系统更多推荐
能够帮到更多普通家庭的孩子
今天直播就到这
各位站
各位同学晚安